So we're going to start backwards somewhat with the public comment one minute and then you can take course longer if you have groups.
So let's can we begin with the public comment?
Yes.
Do you want to begin with the presentation?
Okay, we'll begin with the staff presentation.
Well, good morning President Kerse, Vice President Strauss, Superintendent Torlakson, and members of the State Board.
My name is Stephanie Gregson and I'm the Executive Director of the Instructional Quality Commission and the Director of the Curriculum Frameworks and Instructional Resources Division.
I'm honored to be here today and present to you item number nine, 2016 Revised California Science Framework.
Presenting with me today is the Chair of the Instructional Quality Commission, Lauren Wild.
and the Chair of the Science Subject Matter Committee, Rob Foster.
I'd also like to, before we formally begin our presentation, I'd also like to acknowledge other staff that have been involved in this very long process.
I have my CDE staff, our lead consultant, Dr. Brian Boyd, and our manager, Kristen Cruz-Allen, and Cynthia Gunderson, who supported these efforts.
We also have Dean Reese here, who's another Instructional Quality Commission and contributor to the Science Framework,
and we have many partners in the room as well.
I'd also like to note and acknowledge that this is the last formal framework presentation for Commissioner Chair Lauren Wild as her tenure on the Instructional Quality Commission ends next month.
She will be sorely missed as she's such a strong advocate for high quality instructional support for our teachers across California and she's played that vital role on the Instructional Quality Commission.
So this is her last official one.
Our presentation today includes information on the framework development process, content and features of the framework, and finally, our next steps.
I know you've seen this graphic before, so I'm going to give you a short overview of the science framework development process.
I'm not going to go into detail about each of these boxes.
However, I wanted to note that this process started in the summer of 2013.
I wasn't even here at the CD event.
Throughout this process there have been numerous opportunities for the public to provide input and feedback to make sure that the California Science Framework supports the needs of all teachers and students in California.
This public input was vital in creating the document we are forwarding you today for action.
To begin the development, focus groups meetings were held in January and February 2014 in five locations throughout the state.
Due to a statewide recruitment push, the process of selecting 20 candidates to recommend to the Science Curriculum Framework and Evaluation Criteria Committee, or otherwise known as the Science CFCC, was a difficult task.
In May 2014, the IQC reviewed and deliberated on 172 highly qualified applicants for the Science CFCC.
In July 2014, the state board appointed the 20-member committee.
Of the 20 members, 13 were classroom teachers, three were from county offices, an associate professor from Cal State Long Beach, a regional director from the K-12 Alliance, a project manager from Stanford, and a professor emerita from Stanford.
Almost all of the members had experience working with English learners, and many had worked with students with special needs.
Throughout the process, the IQC and its subcommittee, the Science Subject Matter Committee, followed the work of the CFCC.
At least two IQC members, even three or four, were in attendance at each of the six science CFCC meetings.
Our state board liaisons were also in attendance, member Williams and member Strauss.
Once the initial draft was completed by the CFCC members, the draft framework was ready for comment from the field.
November 17, 2015 through January 19, 2016, the first draft of the science framework was posted for the first 60-day public review period.
The response was extensive, although not as extensive as the history of social science.
The field review survey ended with 638 responses.
Most were from individuals, although there were a few replies that represented a group of educators.
In addition to the survey, members from the public could submit comments to the Science Framework mailbox.
We received over 81 emails in the mailbox, many from County Office of Education and professional educational organizations throughout the state.
One of these groups specifically was the California Science Teachers Association, otherwise known as CSTA,
who held 30 review sessions in 22 counties with over 550 teachers participating in these review sessions.
So after the second 60-day field review from January 28 to August 29, the IQC met on September 22, where all chapters and appendices were recommended to the State Board for action except Chapter 5.
Due to extensive public comment and a feeling from the Instructional Quality Commission that there were some flaws within Chapter 5, the IQC requested the primary writer, who is Matthew D'Alessio, and he is here in this room.
I forgot to mention him in the beginning.
requested that Matthew D'Alessio go back and make major revisions to Chapter 5, specifically the middle school preferred integrated model portion.
The IQC then met on October 14th, very quick turnaround, to review the writer's edits and took action on the recommendations for Chapter 5 because Matthew did an excellent job at rewriting Chapter 5.
and then forwarded to the State Board for action.
I'd like to note that the California Science Framework has truly been a living document throughout these years.
We've learned so much since 2013 with the implementation of California NGSS, and the revisions made to the Science Framework reflect those new learnings.
Hence, the development of the California Science Framework was the epitome of collaboration because of these new learnings.
We received input from the California NGSS early implementers, County Offices of Education, K-12 Alliance, California Science Projects, Resource Area for Teaching, the Monterey Bay Aquarium,
the California Science Center, California Teachers Association, Lawrence Hall of Science, Achieve, we've also received input from the Environmental Roundtable, CalRecycle, Ten Strands, and many others.
The CFRS staff also reached out to other CDE divisions for review and contributions in their area of expertise.
We were fortunate to have division input from the English learner support division, special education, professional learning support, school facilities, early education and support, expanded learning, improvement in accountability, and assessment development and administration divisions.
In total, there were close to 1,874 suggested revisions from the emails we received and over 227 comments from CDE divisions.
So in total, during the entire process, we received over 4,000 comments on our California Science Framework.
So with that, I'm going to turn to Commissioner Wild.
Thank you.
So I have the opportunity to highlight the organization of this framework and really how it was put together.
The first thing that we did is we really looked at and made sure it was aligned to the California NGSS standards.
One of the things we really like to tell people about the frameworks is the standards really serve as the what,
But the frameworks are the how, and we wanted to make sure that the framework really answered the following questions.
How will teachers implement the new standards?
But the most important question is, what is this going to look like in a classroom?
Stephanie mentioned that's why it was so important to us that we had all of these teacher voices from across the state at different levels because these frameworks have started to garner reputation as being really useful tools that teachers can turn to in the classroom.
to be able to have an idea of what do these shifts look like.
The next component that guided the framework was the state board of education guidelines and these were developed with input from our science framework focus groups.
The CDE conducted five focus groups meetings where they asked educators their ideas and they wanted to know you know what do how what do you need to know to
implement these new standards?
Where does there need to be clarity in these standards so that we can help you, you know, frame your instruction?
I had the opportunity to attend one of these focus groups in San Diego, and I can just tell you from that, you know, inception moment, the energy in the room was really high.
We had lots of stakeholders that were asking these questions and educators wanting to understand, you know, how are these new standards with, you know, engineering and cross-cutting concepts, what is this going to look like?
We also wanted to make sure that the California's science framework was consistent with our other greatest hits, which has been the math and the ELA, ELD frameworks, and also ensuring that there were cross-curricular connections, including the ELA and literacy standards, the ELA and ELD standards, and the mathematics standards, and that they contain similar attributes because we recognize, particularly for elementary teachers,
They're looking across all of these frameworks as they're planning instruction, and we wanted to make sure that it was cohesive and consistent.
And so once the State Board of Education will approve this document, over the next five to six years, we anticipate that there will be supporting resources that will be added to the framework, instructional materials, and as the standards are implemented in the field.
So again, as Stephanie mentioned, it's important to note
that these frameworks really mark kind of the beginning of a journey where we really want to continue to have this conversation with educators and be responsive to their needs in the field.
So I'm going to also talk about some of the major instructional shifts that were the instructional focus for this framework.
And the first one is the three-dimensional model, and I can attest that we had many discussions about this three-dimensional model, and I think I can speak for my colleagues on the commission that all of us really, you know, deepened our understanding of what this means and what it means to put this three-dimensional model into action and learning.
And so in the three-dimensional model, students engage in scientific inquiry of phenomena, and this was a really important term that our framework was really built around.
Understanding how we're using all three dimensions of the California NGSS, and those dimensions are our disciplinary core ideas, or oftentimes we refer to as DCIs, the cross-cutting concepts, and the scientific engineering practices.
The other important cornerstone of this framework was that it was, again, coherent across the curriculum, that we were really modeling a framework where learning builds upon itself from year to year, and science is not isolated, but rather it integrates with other parts of the curriculum and other disciplines.
Again, this has been a major theme in our frameworks that we're really showing educators how our content can be woven together so that it's supporting one another.
And again the last part that was really important is that we're focusing on what's relevant to our local communities and student interest.
Science is such an important gateway where students can really learn about themselves and their world and we wanted to make sure that the content was building on their interests and their existing experiences so that they can learn how to solve real world problems.
There's some unique features on how this framework is organized and how we really try to interweave these different ideas.
Examples of how to implement these standards in the classroom are demonstrated through snapshots and vignettes.
You can recall from our other frameworks, snapshots are small glimpses into the classroom, so it might not be a whole lesson, but it offers the teacher a real-life example of what this instruction could look like in a classroom.
And vignettes are longer and more descriptive, so they might cover an entire lesson or a unit of study where teachers can really see how this three-dimensional model of learning can unfold.
There are also engineering design challenges and vignettes to support language development in the science classroom.
All of the chapters include links to references to local, state, and other stakeholder sites for additional information, resources, and research, in addition to a resource section at the end of the document.
And I know one of the questions we get all the time is, you know, we've kind of moved into a 21st century format where these documents live online,
But that's one of the important features of it because as teachers are reading it online, they can access these links quite easily that will take them to these other resource sections right as they're planning.
The other thing that was really important was the integration of the environmental principles and concepts, which are known as the E, P, and Cs.
and they examine the interactions and interdependence of human societies and natural systems and must be addressed in all future California textbooks and instructional materials adopted by the state.
And again, this is really important to California as we recognize, you know, where our learning comes from can come from really the local issues at hand and so the EPNCs really help frame this conversation for our students as they're learning science.
And then the final thing I want to highlight that was really important is again the connection to all of the other standards.
The California Common Core Standards for ELA and ELD, the California English Language Development Standards, and the California Common Core State Mathematics Standards.
These are all represented in the text through grade level chapters and across the vignettes.
Now Rob Foster is going to give us some more information about some of the chapters in their construction.
Thank you.
Make sure I get that right.
So chapter one provides background on the standards and describes how they're organized.
It's the overview chapter that identifies those key instructional shifts that Lauren talked about.
It goes into great detail about what those three dimensions are, how they're important in the three-dimensional learning that we've talked so much about in Next Generation Science Standards.
Environmental principles and concepts are included there, and it ends with how to read the standards document, which is, for me, one of the areas I've worked with most with teachers when I do staff development.
It clearly identifies how to locate the performance expectations and provides descriptions of those dimensions.
So grade span chapters two through six.
These are gonna be probably one of the places that teachers turn to first for guidance in the framework.
There are five grade level chapters, Transitional Kindergarten, Kindergarten through Second Grade, Third through Fifth, Sixth through Eighth, Ninth through Twelfth.
Each chapter begins with an introduction of the grade span, highlighting the three dimensions and how they'll progress over each of the grade level.
Each specific grade level contains a short overview with additional grade specific details in the instructional segments.
And the performance expectations are bundled into these instructional segments with the cross cutting concepts as the main thread that kind of runs through and holds everything together.
There are tables that provide an overview of relevant performance expectations and the topics that will be covered and then further developed in each of those instructional segments.
The intention of the instructional segments is to provide instructional support, suggestions, and possible models for the grade level teachers.
And additionally, it provides connections to what's going on before and after, or the grade levels before and the grade levels after.
Assessment has two fundamental purposes, summative and formative, and I can say we talked about this a lot.
And this is somewhat of a moving target.
We talked a little bit about how things have evolved and changed so much in the last three years, and the idea of what is assessment in a three-dimensional world has probably been one of those areas that we've talked about the most.
The key difference between summative and formative is how the information of the assessment provided is used, either formative, to guide and advance learning,
or summative to take a look at what students have learned and that information is often used outside the classroom.
The concept of three-dimensional learning is very, very new and almost demands a paradigm shift.
In the past, assessment was perhaps multiple choice questions or fill in the blanks focused on the content or facts.
Teachers will find ideas here to support their own use of formative assessment to assist students in guiding their own learning by evaluating and revising
Thinking of their work and in turn supporting students as they get a sense of their own autonomy and responsibility for their learning.
This chapter also provides current plans for statewide science assessment and identifies the SEPs for teachers to use to assess student work.
Chapter 8, Access and Equity.
So this chapter, it's there to help all teachers meet the needs of all their students in our California classrooms.
It discusses the needs of our diverse student population, and these include Standard English Learners, African American English Speakers, Chicano English Speakers, English Learners,
long-term English learners, ethnically diverse learners, migrant students, students living in poverty, foster youth, advanced learners, gifted learners, and students with disability.
Additionally, it provides guidance on how to support girls and young women in science and covers several research-based approaches to positively impact girls' motivation, achievement, and confidence with science and engineering.
And as a teacher and a father of daughters, I am very glad to see that.
The NGSS promotes science and engineering practices and pedagogy that are equity focused.
In particular, student discussion and disciplinary literacy plays a much larger role than with previous standards.
This presents a challenge for teachers to fully understand and include all students in classroom discourse and to address science literacy.
And as a middle school science teacher, I'll tell you, sometimes getting those kids to talk when you want them to can be very problematic.
This chapter provides strategies for those teachers to address these challenges.
Also in this are strategies from Universal Design for Learning, a research-based framework for guiding educational practice.
UDL focuses on planning instruction to meet the varied needs of students.
Also, the multi-tiered system of supports model expands California's response to intervention and instruction process by aligning all systems of high-quality instruction, support and intervention,
and including structures for building, changing and sustaining systems.
So instructional strategies in California and GSS classroom students should use evidence to explain observable phenomena and justify the solution to problems.
Students engage in the scientific inquiry of phenomena using all three of the dimensions of the next generation science standards.
It's important to note that learning builds upon itself from year to year.
and science integrates with other parts of the curriculum.
Most of all, it's relevant to local communities and students' interests.
Content and skills build on students' existing experience to learn about and solve real-world problems.
This chapter highlights some key instructional strategies for sequencing lessons, the 5E instructional cycle, problem-based learning, science talk, and science notebooks to support student learning, just to name a few.
So Chapter 10 addresses the significant shift in changes facing California educators and the educational system in regards to the need for collaboration and leadership as these changes move forward.
It also includes an overview of possible sources for professional learning.
The shared leadership and support for working with many different partners and programs is discussed.
These include working with libraries and model school library standards, collaborating with afterschool and extended learning programs, and developing strong collaboration with parents, families, and community members.
And at this point, I'd like to turn it back over to Dr. Gregson.
So chapter 11, the final chapter before all the appendices, is the criteria for publishers to develop instructional materials.
We needed to make sure the criteria addressed new opportunities for the integration of print and digital alternatives, was specific enough to address the needs of all of the students, while also allowing publishers some freedom to develop materials that are not cost prohibitive.
Another important tool to help teachers instruct and all students to learn is a development and careful selection of high quality instructional resources to support the implementation of the next generation science standards.
Instructional resources are broadly defined to include textbooks, kit-based resources, technology-based resources, other educational resources, and texts.
For grades six through eight, resources must be aligned to either preferred integrated course model or the discipline specific course model.
Board member Rucker talked to you yesterday around our publisher training for history social science.
We're also going to take advantage of our timeline for instructional materials and provide
publisher training around the grade spans within the California Science Framework.
It's really important that we support our publishers in creating high-quality instructional materials that really define the three-dimensional learning within their resources and their core materials, whichever format they choose.
And so we have a responsibility to help them while they have a responsibility to develop high-quality instructional materials.
So with the Science Instructional Materials adoption process beginning in September and Spring 2018, we are afforded that opportunity to support the publishers.
The Instructional Materials recommendations will come before the State Board in November 2018.
This aligns with the new California NGSS science assessment being implemented in the 2018-19 school year with a field test in the 2017-18 school year.
And to continue to help support our local education agencies with the implementation of the California NGSS and our science framework, we are working in partnership with CSTA in developing more snapshots and vignettes to be used as professional learning resources that would be located on our CDE website.
We also have a very solid infrastructure of collaboration within the California science world.
This collaboration helps provide professional learning opportunities and partnerships across California.
More specifically, we have a California Science Framework launch events that are already being scheduled for spring 2017, and we're actually vetting those sessions next weekend, yes, Veterans Day weekend, to make sure that they are quality sessions for our teachers and administrators.
And the purpose of this collaboration infrastructure allows for the building capacity at the local level and enhancing our science instruction across California classrooms where students will be engaged in doing science.
So with that, I would like to note that Dr. Matthew D'Alessio came to us at an opportune time to help
take all of the different voices that were in the first draft of the science framework and make it into one voice, a very coherent and clear document for all of our teachers and administrators.
He's done an outstanding job in taking on that task, meeting all of the deadlines, and reaching out for all of the collaborative support that we have around us in the California science world.
And so I just want to acknowledge all of his hard work and efforts within this entire process, and the job and the tasks that he had to do and complete.
So with that, we're here to answer any questions that you may have.
All science questions are directed at Dr. Matthew D'Alessio.
Okay, so board members, I guess the order of events of checking here with this public hearing Patricia would be We would have board member come questions of the staff, then go to the public comment.
Yes.
And then more board member of discussion.
And then we have a motion.
So okay, so these air questions and technical questions for the
which is very clear and very comprehensive.
So, board member questions.
Board member Williams.
I want to start by saying that I've been involved in the process from the beginning and still have visual images in my head of the meetings in the room when, you know, when everyone was sitting around the table and talking in small groups and debating and figuring all this out.
And it was so very,
complicated, such a change.
The NGSS was such a change over the previous science standards and just getting even all the acronyms down and all of the different pieces of it and everybody knowing, you know, talking about them in the same way and understanding, having a shared understanding of what it meant, developing that.
It took a while, but one of the things I've been so terribly impressed by in this whole journey of NGSS is the enthusiasm of the science teachers.
I don't know that I've ever worked with a group of people that at times have been almost giddy about how much they enjoy the approach of NGSS and believe in it.
and have been waiting for something like this and think it's the best way for students to learn science most deeply and a very contemporary way, very consistent with how the world works now.
Even accepting the bringing into science the engineering practices and the computational thinking and things like that.
So I wanted to start with that and say it's been, for me, it's been an absolute, one of the highlights of my board service has been working with the science teachers and the staff on the curriculum framework.
First the standards and the adoption of the standards and now the curriculum framework.
And for me, trying to help make sure some of the other relevant pieces, like the state summative test, were going to be supportive of this work, as well as bringing the test results into the accountability system.
It's been an absolute pleasure for me.
I'm really proud of this document.
I know there were plenty of places where there were tugs of war over how are we going to do this exactly, and is that right yet, and no, I don't like that.
And there were plenty of places like that, which just goes to show you how important it was to everyone involved.
and how complicated it was to figure out, to make a decision about which is the right way to do it at every one of those potential points of, we could go either way on it.
I think everyone involved did a fabulous job on this, and I think it's a document that is probably, correct me if I'm wrong, the first in the nation curriculum framework on next generation science standards.
And so we should feel really proud about that because it will help support a lot of other states and help hopefully drive some really good instructional materials.
And I'm also particularly proud that we added an appendix on computer science in science because that also makes this a very forward-thinking document.
So all that, congratulations, kudos.
It's been a pleasure.
I have nothing but respect for this entire team and their enthusiasm and energy and intelligence and commitment to students.
I do wish the instructional materials were going to get
done a little close, you know, come on.
I wish that would work out.
That just makes it seem like it's so much further down the road.
But other than that, that's out of my control.
And for this part of the work, just really good work, all of you.
Okay, Board Member Rucker, okay, and then Strauss.
Well, I want to say that in my tenure on the board, this will be the fourth framework that I had the opportunity to monitor and to be involved with as a board member and to collaborate with Board Member Williams and Board Member Strauss in getting that last part of it pushed out.
And I have to say, not just for the science teachers, but for all of the education community that watched this process develop, what was very unique about the development of this particular framework
Unlike the history social science framework, there was a great deal of confluence about the ideals of teaching science, but also the desire to see science have an impact across the curriculum, not about the concepts of science teaching, but about the discipline of study and analysis and a logic model and approach to analysis and understanding or approaching content.
So for the non-science teachers on the IQC.
who also participated in the conversation, even though they weren't members of the framework committee, it was also very helpful for them because it also gave a more human picture and a less expert system approach to the language and the register of English by which the framework was written.
And so I do want to compliment the writer because he has not only as he has an amazing sense of humor to be a science teacher,
and but also he has an amazing amount of patience that called upon him to exercise not only patience but also a great deal of foresight in what the sustained effect of a lot of conversations and recommendations
would need to be.
There was no my way or the highway conversation in making the decisions.
There was a great deal of consensus, a great deal of compromise, and that's how every conversation began and ended.
And so I have to compliment not just the IQC, but the entire team of folks who worked on this process and who were willing to listen to the rest of the people on the IQC who were not the experts, but who saw
you know, other things or other issues that were important to them.
Commissioner Wild, I also have to tell you I will miss you more than I can say because we started together in this process and so it'll be a wonderful thing to see this last framework be launched
not just because it happened under your leadership as a leader of the IQC, but because we have been through so much together, starting with the English Language Arts Framework, and then to see it culminate with the work that you carried through on the principles of teaching English learners into this framework were very important.
In my career, I have watched people have conversations about teaching English and about teaching science and even teaching history, social science,
And this is the first time that we've had a conversation that is inclusive, not just of English learners, but of children with special needs.
Not because they're not in our classrooms, but because somebody has finally recognized this content is relevant to them as well.
So I really have to thank you for doing that.
Well, as the second liaison to science and an ongoing member of IQC with Member Rucker, it's been a pleasure and I just support what Member Williams has said.
We have a couple more people in the audience I want to recognize.
We have another IQC member, Dean Reese, who's a science teacher in Central Valley, and Tracy, I believe.
And Dean's been really important, so Dean, I just want to recognize your work as a
and then Kirk Brown I believe has been, I thought I saw you there, really helpful too from San Joaquin.
There's a huge team, there's some other people I think standing behind Rob Foster that I don't see, but Cliff and anyway, lots of the team.
If you guys would just stand who's worked on this from CDE level and everyone who's here.
This was an incredible team effort and I just wanna recognize all the people here who worked really, really hard on this.
So thank you all very, very much.
So, I just would say, being out in the field and talking to people about the work, I share what Member Rucker and Member Williams are saying.
There's a huge excitement about this.
People are ready.
As we know, in 17 years we've learned a little bit more about science and this framework really is far more current.
And while it will take the publishers time to develop aligned materials for our framework, I think the framework will allow districts, that's what I say, is they need to get started now if they haven't been already working on what the NGSS is and what the framework, it will help lay the foundation so when the materials come, there'll be good consumers and reviewers of potential adopted materials as well.
So, and then I just want to thank, I saw Lisa Hegnolan from CSTA.
So, the Science Teachers Association have been an amazing partner in this process, even in CTC working on credentialing requirements.
They've been really helpful.
It's really been making our work much richer with the input that they have with a lot of these comments, if you look at that.
So, just Lisa and your whole organization, Jessica, everyone who's worked really hard from CSTA.
This was a collaborative process truly and really an exemplar for our work going forward.
We have lots more.
We have other frameworks and we're in the process of updating all of them.
Health is coming next.
We have arts to do, PE, world language is coming.
So again, we're going through this process.
This has been a long time in coming that is a really exemplar for the nation, I think.
So just a congratulations to the effort.
And I'm excited to hear some of the public comments on this.
I want to thank Stephanie and Lauren and Rob for a really thorough presentation.
Those people who hadn't followed us closely, I think you really helped highlight the shifts in the framework and what the tools are.
And then just a follow-up to our commitment for literacy for all.
The literacy standards that are in the ELA, ELD framework, that are also in the history social science framework, that are in this framework, and we're putting in the math framework, we have made a commitment that all of our frameworks, as we update them, will include literacy strategies through that content area.
So Lauren, for your work as a literacy coach, and now an administrator leading the work at a school, we really want to thank you.
And for Rob, your continued work in science,
It's been a wonderful contribution and we'll look forward to celebrating in two weeks at IQC and honor your leadership, Lauren.
So thank you all very, very much.
Okay, other board member comments before you'll have another chance?
Okay, I think we're ready for public comment.
Oh, I now declare the public hearing opening.
We have six speakers, Lisa Hegdahl, Gerald Lieberman, Will Parrish, Brian Ehlers, Jerry Valadez, and Stephen Blake.
Good morning State Superintendent Torlakson, President Kirst, members of the board.
My name is Lisa Hegdahl and I'm president of the California Science Teachers Association.
Today I am speaking on behalf of our over 3,000 CSTA members, but I'll admit that I'm also speaking for myself.
I look around this room and I think of the hours I have spent in here.
As a member of the CFCC, as president of CSTA, providing public comment about the California Science Framework, speaking to the Science Subject Matter Committee, the Instructional Quality Commission, the State Board of Education.
It's been a lot of hours, and it's been a lot of drafts, and it's been a lot of pages.
But now today, I am delighted to say that CSTA supports the recommendation of the CDE and the IQC to adopt the California Science Framework with edits from the second 60-day public review period.
We want to sincerely thank the California Department of Education for the many opportunities provided to CSTA members and to the education community in California to provide feedback to the framework.
We'd also like to thank the CFCC members, the IQC, the Science Subject Matter Committee members, the State Board of Education, the writers, the public, everyone who has provided input and guidance during this process.
Moving forward, CSTA will continue to collaborate with the CDE and our partners.
Thank you for your- Go ahead, you can finish, yeah.
All right.
We would like to continue that collaboration as we move forward with the implementation process and move forward with the implementation of NGSS as a whole.
Thank you so much.
Good morning, President Kirsten, members.
I'm Stephan Blake representing Children Now.
I want to echo all the very strong and strongly positive remarks you've been hearing this morning about what a remarkably collaborative and inclusive process this has been.
Children Now had many of its concerns about expanding the treatment of engineering and computer science and focusing on equity and laboratory science.
addressed within the different drafts through the entire range of processes and committees.
We really want to commend the writers, the staff of the Science Curriculum Framework Committee, the IQC, your remarkably passionate liaisons who have been involved so deeply in this for three or four years now, and so we strongly endorse your adoption of this draft.
Thank you.
Good morning, members of the State Board of Education.
I'm Will Parrish, founder of 10 Strands, a nonprofit corporation advancing environmental literacy in all our schools.
I taught high school environmental science and civics in SFUSD for 10 years.
I served on the NGSS California review team.
and on the CA-NGSS coalition.
I was appointed to the Instructional Quality Commission in 2009 and served as the chair of the Science Subject Matter Committee, and I served on the Environmental Literacy Task Force and am now co-chair of the Environmental Literacy Steering Committee.
Oh, there we go.
I'm also a member of the Science Collaboration Committee.
So I want to support the State Board of Ed's adoption of the draft California Science Framework as written and with the IQC recommended edits.
I'm especially delighted to note the inclusion of California's environmental principles and concepts throughout the framework.
The ability of environment-based education to spark inquiry, interest, and engagement in students makes it especially appealing to teachers.
Using the students' own environment will help assure that teaching science will be engaging, meaningful, and worthwhile, and provide students with the education they need to become productive, successful 21st century members of the workforce and citizens.
Thank you.
Good morning, all.
My name is Jerry Lieberman.
I'm the director of the State Education and Environment Roundtable.
I want to echo, I've been working with the CDE team, Dr. Adams and everybody else on the staff.
It's been a wonderful experience.
Their openness, Dr. Alessio has been a fabulous person to work with.
He's more than just a scientist.
He does have a great sense of humor, actually.
I'd like to point out two things that are in the framework and I think that are critically important to us all.
One of the key instructional shifts relevant to local communities and student interests.
Content and skills build on students' existing experience to learn about and solve real-world problems.
Incredible.
We're actually going to make science grab their attention and interest.
It's crucial.
The second piece I want to point out, and it's related since I've been working on the environmental principles and concepts since 2004, is the other paragraph that introduces the beyond the three dimensions.
Broadly defined, the environment is the context in which we live our lives.
It includes high mountain meadows and cool, clear streams, the air we breathe, the water we drink, and the soils in which we grow the food we eat.
The environment also encompasses the communities in which we live.
Thank you.
Please support this.
Good morning, Superintendent Torlakson and distinguished board members.
My name is Jerry Valadez, longtime science educator.
In fact, going back to the first advisory committee of the California Science Project back in 1988, numerous committees, including the science expert panel.
And I'm here again to endorse adoption of the framework.
This is my third framework in my career and excited about it.
However, I do urge
for another look in revisions of Chapter 8.
In this era where we are reliving civil rights, there are grave concerns that I have that we have about Chapter 8.
And the structure of the chapter is way too long.
There's redundancy, there's ambiguity, and for example, talking about integrated ELD and NGSS to replace scaffolding, and then there's a whole section on scaffolding.
That's just one example.
I urge to reconsider this chapter, call in experts to take a look at it.
I absolutely urge you to remove STEAM.
There is no evidence and research to back up STEAM, and that's in the second page of chapter eight, and it has no business being there.
Thank you.
Morning, President Kurtz, members of the board, Superintendent Torlakson.
My name is Brian Ehlers.
I am the director of the Office of Education and the Environment with CalRecycle, also known as the California Department of Resources, Recycling and Recovery.
We're a regulatory agency.
So what am I doing here?
There was legislation that was referenced just a moment ago that was passed back in 2003, which Superintendent Horlickson was a co-author, and it was responsible for putting the environmental principles and concepts on the map, and today, hopefully with your approval, those environmental principles and concepts will be integrated into the teaching of science, just as they were in the history social science framework that you approved a few months ago.
This is a landmark, frankly, in the country, and the world is watching.
And I just want to appreciate the support that the EPNCs have received throughout this process from CDE, from the IQC, from the original drafters of the framework, the work that's gone in from the writers and from Dr. Lieberman to help really make this an integration.
This collaboration between an environmental agency and folks invested in environmental literacy and the broader education community is really a credit to California.
I'm here on behalf of my agency, the Cal EPA, as well as the California Natural Resources Agency to give full-throated support to the framework.
Thank you.
This concludes the public comment.
I declare the public hearing closed and so we're now ready for more board discussion.
If I may, President Kurtz, just also commend all the parties who pulled this together and were so creative and passionate and creating this excitement in the science teacher education field.
Like Rob Foster, I'm a science teacher by background and the father of two daughters, so I particularly appreciated the emphasis on girls and young women in science and what we can do to support their career pathways and their understanding and enjoyment of science.
I also particularly thought the engineering
Focus is really important as part of the new three dimension.
And environmental literacy, as a number of speakers have focused, it's really important and it helps bring the science alive in everyday challenges we have figuring out what to do about global warming and many other forms of threat to the environment.
And as well, just fantastic, fabulous, awesome work.
Wanted to commend that and say thanks to everybody.
I'm ready to make a motion that the State Board adopt the curriculum framework with the recommended edits.
I second.
If there's no further board discussion, the motion is there.
All those in favor, raise your hands.
Okay, well this has been a long effort, started in 2013, my god.
Okay, we're now ready to move on to the next item, which is item 10 on the performance report for special education.
And former SBE staff member, welcome back with a new hat, Kristen Wright, will present.
Go ahead.
Good morning, President Kirst, members, superintendent.
Is it on?
It doesn't sound.
Yes.
Can you hear me?
Yeah.
OK.
I bring excitement and optimism from the special education division in my new role week eight.
So I'm here today to sort of give you a state of the state around students with disabilities, our data, and to let you know that one of our responsibilities is to report to the Office of Special Education Programs around how our students with disabilities are doing, what they look like across various subgroups within students with disabilities, and so I'm here today to present that information to you.
I also just want to acknowledge
Board Member Rucker's comments about the science framework, and while we all know that HOPE is not a plan, and I am very hopeful for students with disabilities, the fact that we are paying special and close attention to ensuring that all of our students have access to the standards and to assessments that are based on the standards, and I mean every student, is really encouraging, so thank you.
Just to also point out that this data is lagging.
It's a year behind, so it's from the count from last December, but that's how we report to the feds.
So this presentation's in two parts, and the first part is really the state of the state around where we are with students with disabilities.
Before I show you the data, I just wanted to point out a couple things.
One, our job, which is really to support and monitor local educational agencies in meeting the customized learning needs of our students with disabilities.
The whole idea of one coherent system that we've all been talking so much about,
all this time, really recognizes all of our students as general education students.
So before I move on, I just wanted to point out that we're making a very concerted effort in the special education division and also across the department
to talk about language and the language that we use about our students.
And so, throughout this presentation, you'll see these terms, students with disabilities, students with individualized education programs, students with exceptional needs, and students who receive special education services.
These are all what I would consider appropriate ways to refer to our students.
What you will not hear me saying and what I hope that we can shift to is moving away from the term special education student because it seems sort of hypocritical to the belief that all students are general education students and then we're calling some students special education students.
So, in the interest of People First Language and a commitment to changing the culture around this conversation, we're going to make an effort for everything coming out of our division to reflect these terms.
And these are all terms that are in statute as well.
As we talk about serving more students in more inclusive environments, it's important to look at how we're looking at our students around the tenets of local control and also around how we look at them in LCFF.
And if you look at this particular graph, this shows our categories for LCFF and really our student population of students with disabilities that fit within this category.
So our overall population of students with disabilities in California is 10.8%.
But if you look at these graphs, you'll see that those student populations are more greatly represented in those populations.
So I think that's just another reason why, as we consider how to align all of our resources, it's important to know that we're talking about the same students.
Again, this is sort of the overall picture that of students with disabilities, 70% of them fall into one or more of the LCFF categories, and we've talked about this in the past, but I just think it's important to remember that this isn't a separate set of students in a separate place.
These are our same students that we're all working with who may also be English learners or students in poverty or foster youth.
I think it's also important to point out, and I would love to look into more of what this means, but our overall student population since 2005 and six has gone down, but our special ed population has gone up.
So in considering how we're serving kids and all these ideas that we're talking about around universally designed for learning classrooms and how do we reach more students in the general education environment,
What we'd like to see is maybe not an increase in students with disabilities in the label, but rather we're doing great early intervention, great preschool, really helping address kids' needs early.
And in a few slides, I'll get into sort of who the kids are, because I think what you'll see is most of our students with disabilities are not students with significant disabilities.
They're students with speech and language issues and with specific learning disabilities.
So here is what it looks like by disability.
And specific learning disabilities, speech and language, and autism combined make up the majority of our students in this category of students with disabilities.
And the all others category is one that includes most of our low incidence disabilities, deaf and hard of hearing, and visually impaired.
So here's the numbers.
To no surprise, you'll see that students with autism have increased 180 percent since 2005.
That's significant.
What I also want to point out is the increase in other health impairment, and this is another area that we may want to look into qualitatively because what you'll also see is emotional disturbances
been reduced by 11%.
So we're not sure what that means in terms of if kids are getting labeled something else or if there's truly an increase or decrease.
So in terms of by ethnicity, I found this data interesting because what we look for is that we have the same percentage represented in special ed by ethnicity as we would in the general population.
And what you'll see is it's fairly close.
And so we have a little disparity,
the Asian population is underrepresented in special education, and our African-American population is slightly higher, but overall we're fairly consistent.
A couple percentage points, right?
Yes.
And I'm not saying that that's okay, but I'm just
I personally thought that the disparage would look different than this, and so while it would be important to look qualitatively at what categories different ethnic groups are in, and I heard Felicia in the back of my mind saying yes.
Yes.
Category may what?
By emotionally disturbed, I would anticipate seeing a disproportionate number of African-American students, and in particular, African-American males.
And that is one of the areas that we definitely look at and that we have very closely ongoing monitoring around, both disproportionality and significant disproportionality.
We identify districts and work with them on that specifically.
And also, even though it's only 2% that have actually been identified, what's more important is what's the numbers or the information that's behind this 2%.
Because that also means, even though it's a relatively slightly higher number of over-identified, it also means that there's a significantly high number of over-referrals.
and it's going to be significantly different among all of those categories including severe emotional disturbance because a lot of times African-American students are being referred more for behavioral issues than for issues that are really related to having a specific educational need.
So the two percent
You know, I've heard, you know, sitting on this panel, I've actually heard board members say, well, even if it seems discriminatory, it's only small or it's only a little bit, it's still, the number still says that there are some discriminatory practices that are happening, particularly concerning this subgroup of students.
And I agree with you, and I think every number, every student matters in this scenario, and what I would say about this in general is that as we work with districts, we help them unpack not only the students who have already been identified, but what their process is for identification, and that's really critical.
And I know that you've heard me have this conversation with Fred and Fred has come back to the Commission while you were on the Advisory Commission to talk about this because this is something that's in California's plan that they have a monitoring plan for and they've been doing work on.
This is important and it does.
It impacts more than just this subgroup of students or even this subcategory of planning in the overall plans.
This goes back to the school climate issues and some of those other elements of accountability that we're still really beginning to unpack in the LCAP because this is what this is also related to.
And I'm glad you pointed to that because it's part of the big picture and as we're unpacking all those accountability measures,
This really needs to play a role, and so we're happy to be at the table around those conversations.
So thank you for bringing that up.
I completely agree.
Yes, so I knew this report was coming, so I waited on that piece just to be able to say, here's the data that needs to inform that conversation.
And we're happy to provide you with any data moving forward as well around each of these individual conversations.
So as we look at our English learners in California, this is what it looks like in terms of what languages they're speaking, and we just thought this would be good for you to know.
Probably no surprise here, but again, these are the languages.
One other area that is close and near and dear to my heart, and I think really part of the catalyst that's going to help change the culture and climate of more inclusive beliefs and a community that believes that everyone belongs is in preschool.
And if you look at the speech and language, the percentage of students in preschool that have speech and language disabilities, and you think about the opportunities for inclusive preschool for students with disabilities three to five, something just doesn't
sit right with me around that and that's because we know that students with speech and language disabilities need a lot of opportunity for speech and language and communication and social emotional learning and so
One of the areas that we'll definitely be focusing on more, and I'll be working with our director of early childhood, and we've already started having these ongoing conversations, is how do we assist LEAs in creating more blended programs so that our students with disabilities have opportunities for inclusive preschool options, so that we can get them on a different trajectory, so we're not leading them on a trajectory of segregation.
So here is preschool students with individual education plans by ethnicity, fairly consistent with our overall population as well.
So now, as you know, we have to do, we have 17 indicators that the federal government requires us to monitor and report on, and as my accommodation, I'm gonna bring my brilliant data manager, Shiloh Vesriel, up here to present this to you, because this is her bailiwick, and she spends day and night working with this data, and it's an area that I feel really proud of in our division.
We have a great,
data team, and we're really nothing without our data because it's really what drives how we monitor and how we do our work.
So I look forward to future conversations.
I will be back to see you in March to tell you more of our plans for our state improvement system, and thanks for having me.
Good morning, board members.
Thank you for having me.
I'm going to present to you some of the nuts and bolts of our annual performance report.
This report is a required report by the U.S.
Department of Education.
It is one of the required elements to continue our IDEA grant.
So for California receives about $1.1 billion from the federal government.
In order to keep that money flowing, we have to submit several items, and this is one of the items.
So we require your approval in order to submit this item to the U.S.
Department of Education.
There are 17 indicators.
Some of them are compliance and some of them are performance.
And so for our compliance elements, it's important to remember the U.S.
Department of Education has a zero tolerance.
The target is 100% or zero.
So as I go through it, you'll see that some of the targets are zero or 100%.
And sometimes we miss it by very few students.
It's okay, I don't need that.
I got this.
So our performance elements are things where we set the targets based on our current sets of data and how districts we believe will be doing.
So we've set targets all the way through 2018-19, and so you'll see the targets align much closer with the data.
So going forward, I wanted to also call out that there's several different data sources for the data provided here.
I'll go through some of the pieces of the data, but there's data that comes from our CALPADS, our longitudinal data system, but we also have a special education data system that we collect.
from electronic IEPs at the district, and that also provides us data for this report.
We also receive data from the Office of Administrative Hearings.
So those are the sources of data.
I will tell you we're very excited that within the next five years, we are going to be bringing KSMIS, which is a very old program, into CALPADS.
So we will have one system of data for all of our students.
We really believe that there should be, there's one student that sits in the classroom, and so there should just be one set of data about them.
So we're very excited about that.
Some of the data here is represented in 15-16, but some of it is lag year, and I can point that out to you.
But indicators one, two, and four are in lag years.
The executive summary, the item that you all have had, goes through a process where it gives a description of each indicator, what the targets are, what the reported results, and some of our improvement activities around it.
So you'll see that in the item.
I'm not gonna go through every single indicator just because
It's a little bit long, and nobody wants to listen to that data presentation so early in the morning.
But I did want to point out a few things.
I've bunched some of the indicators here into our compliance indicators.
These are the ones represented on this chart.
Going back to Member Rucker and Member Ortiz's concerns about disproportionality, what we do with disproportionality is we do calculations to determine districts who are disproportionate.
and then we request that we review their records to ensure that their disproportionality is not due to inappropriate practices or policies.
I will tell you that the U.S.
Department of Education is intending to change this, and the way that they're intending to change it is to change our calculation methodology.
So we should see within, by the end of this year, that they're gonna come out with new regulations around this, and it will be something that we will be working on.
We have anticipated these changes,
Um, these changes, and so we may see an additional number of disproportionate districts because the calculation is changing.
So you may see many more districts when we come here next year.
I'm just sort of pre stressing you for that.
You remember?
Oh, she said that.
But you will see that all of these targets are 0 100.
Huh?
Oh, it's okay, you can be mad.
But just remember that I said it next year.
You'll see here that the targets are zero or 100% and you'll see that for many of these we missed it by just very, very few students.
One of the areas that we are a little bit concerned about is our Part C to Part B transition.
In the previous years, we've been around 98% two years ago, 93% this last year, and now we're at 86%.
That's about 1,400 children who are missing this transition period.
And if you don't understand what this means, it means that students who are in our infant program, they need to be transitioned into the preschool program by age three.
We are not the administrators of the Part C program.
That is the Department of Developmental Services.
So it makes it a little bit more complicated for us to make that transition and help districts make that transition.
So we're not sure what's causing this drop.
We are going to be working with the Department of Developmental Services to develop some joint communications to both districts.
and to regional centers so that they understand what the requirements are around transitioning these Children from the infant program into the preschool program, and we hope that next year we will see a drop in this.
Actually, an increase in this compliance.
Um, I would also like to highlight to you all that
In our secondary transition, if you remember a few years ago, we were actually at about 85% of our students had transition plans.
So these are children who are 15 years or older.
They have to have a transition plan, so they are prepared to go to be college and career ready.
And what we were finding was that many of those students didn't have that plan.
So we put in a pretty aggressive level of monitoring, and now we are at 99.6% of students have a plan.
So I think we missed about 535 students throughout the state did not have a plan out of almost 127,000.
So you can see through our monitoring efforts, we are able to improve our compliance levels.
So now to some of the more exciting stuff, which is our performance indicators.
There's lots of them in your item.
There is these charts, which goes through all of the performance and compliance indicators.
I'm not going to go through them all.
I just wanted to highlight them so that you could see which ones they were.
These are also the performance indicators.
Graduation is one of the performance indicators I'd like to point out to you today.
You'll see that we are at 64.5% of our students are graduating within four years.
This is an increase from the previous year and it's also an increase from the year before that.
One of the reasons why we find this to be a little bit lower than what we would expect is because this uses a four-year adjusted cohort rate.
So students enter in ninth grade, they have four years to receive a regular diploma.
But we find many of our students take five or six years.
They still receive that regular diploma, but they take a little bit longer.
Unfortunately, for the purposes of this calculation, we are not permitted to include them.
So they are considered completers, but they are not considered graduates for the purposes of our federal reporting process.
So I did want to highlight that for you so you would understand why the percentage is a little bit lower than what we would expect.
Absolutely.
Is it the same for general education graduation rate calculations?
One of the reasons why we have to use the four-year adjusted cohort rate is because that's what general education uses.
That was what was in our ESCA workbook.
So as we're moving through our ESSA accountability, it would be important for us to include students who graduate in five or six years.
Yeah, just let me follow up.
I mean, this is quite a not just for special ed, but controversial issue that you can't count any fifth year graduates.
And I guess in our accountability systems for federal aid, we can't use any fifth year graduates.
So
It's so we're talking about getting a more complete picture.
This is something we may want to look over at over time.
Do we want to look at fifth year graduates rather than just ignoring it and see what it looks like and what impact it has?
And we would be happy to bring data to the board so they could see actually what this would look like over five years or six years so they could see that our students do actually will get a diploma within five or six years.
I think that's something that we... General ESSA plan pursue looking at the five-year so we can get a fuller picture because some students take longer, something happens in their life, some tragedy or something gets them off track, and some just take longer, and why not count them?
And we have some credit-to-credit recovery programs out there that work, and you know, go ahead, Board Member Ortiz-Lacombe.
Yes, when we have that conversation, though, can we also know who are the students that are, one of my hesitations would be that if we have a fifth year option, then some students may be tracked or encouraged to take that fifth year, which has been a historical pattern.
So while we want to make sure that our students graduate, which is the goal, and it may take a little longer for some students,
We also want to know what could be the unintended consequences of that action.
And so I think this is when data really needs to be part of that.
And that was my comment.
I'm not sure how far we track.
Do we track to sixth year?
Do we have that data?
And are we able to look at subgroups and things like that?
I think it would be really helpful for us to see that overall.
Because I see Ernie Silva sitting out in the audience, this is a conversation he has constantly brought to the board to pay attention, not only to this issue as it relates to alternative students and alternative programs, but also in looking at the graduation rates and the way we calculate it for special ed students.
I agree, however, with Board Member LeCone that we have to be careful about how we incorporate this as an exception or as an, is it an outlier or is it something, is it a real mitigating factor?
I think it should inform, particularly since our accountability plan and the ESSA plan does require us to pay attention to the graduation rate and intervene in high schools whose graduation rate hovers somewhere around this number.
But I think if we look at the fifth-year cohort and use it more as a mitigating factor, something that is supportive of the fact that they are turning students out and moving them along, I think that that's a way to inform it.
But I do agree with her concern that if we expand this or figure out some way to be inclusive of this and give them credit, that we will see students being pushed into a fifth-year graduation rather than trying to graduate on time.
But we all agree we would like to look at this in many dimensions, because right now, we just did, I think in the six years I've been here, we've never had a discussion of what's going on in later years.
It strikes me as bizarre, in special ed and in other areas.
I'll be happy to bring that data back to you all so you can see it.
Did I lose the mic?
Okay, I'd also like to bring some of your attention to the dropout rates.
You'll see here that we've had a decrease in our dropout rate from 17% to 14%.
Unlike the graduation rate, this is not a four-year rate.
So this is going to be a little bit higher because it is a one-year rate.
It is one of those requirements from the U.S.
Department of Education that we use a one-year rate.
which, unfortunately, what happens is we'll have situations like, the reason we had this 17% was because LA Unified had students who dropped out, but then they were able to recover them the next year, and now they're actually in school and working towards their diploma, whereas they were considered a dropout from the previous year.
So we're seeing some of the decrease in that, and we hope we'll see more decrease as we go on, but it's gonna be a little bit higher than what you would expect, in part because it is a one-year rate.
I would also like to bring your attention to the statewide assessments data.
We had three indicators for statewide assessments, the adequate yearly progress, AYP, which we will not be reporting because we're going through our new assessments and our new ESSA accountability.
We have to report our participation rates and our percent proficient, which is now the percent meeting standards and above.
Yes, absolutely.
Okay, so I do have a question on the participation rate.
I know that there is under ESSA this idea about the assessments we give for the students who are the 1%.
So I just want to make sure I say this so that it's in our discussion and in the record at this level.
That 1% is a statewide cap of the number of students who can take that test.
That 1% is not a cap we can actually place at the LEA level.
Is that correct?
That is correct.
So for the purposes of our reporting, we have a one percent cap.
However, we cannot, in students who take that alternative assessment, that is an IEP team decision and so we're not able to enforce a cap onto the LEAs.
So in other words, if you do have IEP teams that have identified a number of their students and they've made this decision at those students,
should take the alternative assessment and then they write that into the IEP, even if it exceeds the 1% cap, that is not a cap, that is a restriction at the LEA level.
But it is something the state has to consider.
Has there been a problem for the state about that 1% cap?
In previous years when we had the previous alternate assessment, this was an issue.
We had an upwards of 15 or 20 percent taking the alternative assessments.
We don't believe that that's going to be an issue now with the new computer-based assessments because they're so much more adaptive to students and they offer many more of the ranges of accommodations for students.
And I'm glad you brought that up because I did have a chance to meet with the SBAC team who developed the accessibility manual and one of the things that they have worked on is to make clear to LEAs in the guidance for the manual that the accessibility tools that are available are not just for IEP students but it's available for all students in the LEA and so I think that that's also going to be helpful.
Yes, you will see on the participation rates that are presented here that does not include students who took the Cal-Alt because the Cal-Alt was in field tests last year and so we could not include it for these purposes.
So we would see an increase in our participation rate based on students who took the Cal-Alt next year.
I would also like to point out that we did see an increase in many of our rates for proficiency, especially in the areas of ELA.
You know, we still have some work to do in some of the areas, other areas, of course, but we are seeing an increase over the previous year.
So we hope it will continue to increase.
So this is kind of a more general question, but it comes up here because of the conversation we had yesterday about scale scores versus percent proficient.
And it just strikes me a little bit as I hear you go through these indicators and we have over the several prior years.
that how aligned ESSA and what's going to be our integrated accountability system is with the requirements from OSEP for compliance.
And if they're saying, we want you to report percent proficient by subgroup, and we're going, that's not the way we want to report for general education students, and especially general education students who have exceptional needs,
and additional services required.
So how do we have that conversation with the feds?
I think it is a really good time to have that conversation with the U.S.
Department of Education.
The office that is our regulatory body is the Office of Special Education Programs.
They are probably going to have a new director soon.
They have an interim director at this point.
But once they have a permanent director, it might be a really good time to have the conversation.
They have not made any updates to their requirements in our reporting, but I will tell you also IDEA has not been reauthorized.
When was it last reauthorized? 2004.
I believe was the last reauthorization, I think.
It might have been 2008, but it is due for reauthorization.
It's been due for reauthorization for a few years now.
They had the ESSA that passed, and so they were waiting on that.
Now there's an election year, so I'm not sure what's gonna happen with IDEA.
That's one of the problems is that it does not align.
IDEA does not align with ESSA.
ESSA, and so it has become an issue.
But that said, I think that it's important to note that when IDEA was reauthorized in 2004, there was a conscious effort in three large policy areas to make sure that there was some clear alignment on teacher certification requirements, which actually created more confusion in California than it actually resolved
but also on the accountability and reporting pieces.
So I think a case can be made and the conversation can be had with both divisions in the department that oversee these two different programs about how we want to do that reporting, because we're given that clear flexibility and I don't think, well, I am hopeful that that should not become a major obstacle, not only in developing the ESSA plan, but in doing the reporting for your plan.
I think it's a good time to have the conversations definitely with the US Department of Education as well.
I'd also like to bring your attention to our least restrictive environment indicator.
Now, Director Wright was talking a little bit about how we are really focusing on moving students into their least restrictive environment.
Having a disability should be a ticket in and not a ticket out of general education, and so keeping students within their least restrictive environment.
So we have three ways that we calculate this.
Students who are in the regular classroom 80% of the day or more, students who are in the classroom less than 40% of the day, or students who are in separate environments.
And so the data that we have shows that we're actually about 50% of our students, a little bit more than that, are in the regular classroom more than 80% of the day, which is good, but we would wanna see that increase.
I will tell you, a few years ago, our targets for this indicator were very high, something around 76%.
Many, many, many districts were not meeting that.
We looked at the data, we looked at how the results were over the last five years and found that this,
data was very, very flat, that we weren't seeing any change.
And so we decided to make the targets much more data-driven.
And so based on that, we changed the targets to sort of a more reasonable place, because if you were at a district who had 60% and the target was 76%, you may have felt like, we'll never get there.
But if we made the targets much more data-driven, then we could see where districts would be able to improve.
And what we saw was, even though it's a very small percentage increase, we did start to see an increase last year, and we hope to continue to push that increase and push more students who are capable and who are able into the regular education classroom.
But we're well above the national average in students not in the regular classroom, correct?
Yes, so we're obviously many, we're probably about the middle of the road in terms of students who are in the classroom 80% of the day or more, but in terms of the students who are in separate schools and things like that, we're a little bit higher than the national average.
So you just said you want to push this percentage higher.
How do you do that?
How do you push this percentage?
What is the means for this to change in a district?
We work with our monitoring efforts to identify districts who are struggling in this area, and so who are not meeting this target, and we work with them to see how are you really identifying students for their proper placement, and how can we improve your percentage.
Is there a way that we can create alternative means, multi-tiered systems of support, and I have Director Wright here who's going to speak more to that.
And she just mentioned some of the key words.
So definitely across the state, and we have a huge initiative right now to look at
the MTSS, the Multi-Tiered Systems of Support framework.
And within that, that whole tier one idea of having more universally designed classrooms, more co-planned lessons, really helping general education and special education teachers work together, now they're being trained together, we have a different outlook.
We're hoping that, and our plan is to support districts and schools in moving towards that whole mentality.
So the broader our teachers are able to teach a wider range of students,
And not even just students with disabilities, but students who are English learners and that a lot of them have the same needs around visual support and more language and a lot of things.
So that is really our goal is to help provide resources, professional learning and training and working with our other divisions in the CDE to have a common message around what we think needs to happen in schools.
And I think, Kristen, I'm glad to know that the department has that as the concerted effort because in my experience as a former classroom teacher, especially in dealing with and working with students who are English learners, one of the great frustrations we always saw was trying to identify if there's a learning need for students who are English learners.
Is it a language issue or is there really a learning disability issue?
And so doing the work with multiple, multi-tiered systems of support
actually can mitigate some of those issues as well.
So I think that that's an excellent plan and I think it's going to take the arc of time to see real results from that, but I think that that is correct and the best way to go.
So I was gonna actually bring that point up.
I know that there's cases where ELs are overrepresented as special ed students.
Oh, no, I'm sorry.
Let me go back to my terminology list, sorry.
I apologize.
Students with exceptional needs, and sometimes they're underrepresented because there's confusion.
Is this a need or is it language?
And under Title III, we will have to report now on the number of students that are ELs and also identified under that particular category.
I'm still learning the terminology.
Will that be reflected in your annual report that you submit and will we be able to sort of monitor is a number increasing, decreasing of number of EL students that are also identified?
It's not currently in our annual report that we submit to the U.S.
Department of Education, but here's a secret.
We can present to you all and present in our public reporting anything that we would like.
So if that's something that the board feels is very important, we would be happy to include it in our annual reporting to you all so it could be posted publicly for all of Californians to see.
Well, and because we're gonna be collecting that data under Title III and reporting on it.
The other question that I had,
David, were you gonna say something?
How long, my son had an IEP for speech, and this is, he exited the program this year, so would he be captured for this current data, because it's one year behind, how long are they captured in that category?
Is it just once you exit, that's it?
Or are they captured thereafter as well?
You actually bring up an excellent point when we're talking about things like graduation or performance or assessments.
We only look at students who are, for that year, a student with a disability.
So, for example, your son would no longer be included in our performance indicators.
But that doesn't mean the work that the educators have done to really improve their performance hasn't counted.
And so I think, for example, for our English language learners, they're actually tracked for a couple years afterwards to see how they're doing.
And that might be something that we also choose to do.
I also want to point out to Felicia's point that currently legislation was just signed by the governor around English learners with disabilities and students with disabilities for English learners.
And so we will be working over the next year to develop guidance between the EL division and our division around this particular issue.
So we have a heavy focus on it, so does
Nationally, there's also a focus on it, as you know, so we will continue to do work and provide you with whatever data you need.
Okay, the final indicator that I wanted to bring to your attention would be our post-secondary.
This is post-school outcomes.
So we actually track students after they've exited if they're 14 years or older and see how they're doing one year post-exit.
So these are students who exited in 14-15 and we were tracking them in 15-16 and this is the data that's provided here.
We look at three
levels.
We look at students who are enrolled in higher education, we look at students who are enrolled in higher education and who are competitively employed, and we look at students who are who are competitively employed in higher education or in some other kind of education or employment.
and you'll see that we're still not meeting, we weren't meeting the target last year for students who are in post-secondary education, but we are meeting now all three targets, and we've seen an increase overall of all three of our targets.
This is, sometimes people are concerned about this because this is not data that we match, say, to the Employment Development Division.
This is our local education agencies tracking these students, so they're finding these students after the year and seeing how they're doing.
But we're actually able to get data on about 18,000 students because our LEAs are really using innovative methods to track these students, either through social media, through getting their emails when they're exit and following them, instead of the paper survey, which was what was used in the past.
So we're actually very proud to see that we're getting more data, and we think we're getting better data, even though we are not yet matched to any of our post-secondary.
Yeah, Board Member Paladay.
I don't know very much about the post-secondary programs or process, but I do know a county that has a program for 18 to 22-year-olds of students with disabilities, and they continue to work through a transition phase geared to help them enroll in a college or be on track for a career.
Would these numbers,
include those or no those students are still we actually serve students all the way through age 22 and so some students who have not received a diploma or who are in transition they would you consider them still in the they're still in the program so they would not be included in this data board member rocker okay so among those three categories
I'm confused because I think there's some overlap, especially with, okay, so.
It's just sort of a widening net as we go through it.
Okay, I just wanted to make sure, I wanted to make sure the coffee hadn't kicked in incorrectly and I was seeing an overlap that wasn't, okay.
Yeah, so it's sort of a wider net.
So 14A, which is students who are in post-secondary education, then we widen the net to include all those students plus students who were competitively employed, and then the widest net is 14C, which is students who are in any kind of education or employment.
Okay.
Final, I'm sorry, I will be very quick.
Coming in March, we will be reviewing our state systemic improvement plan, which you all have seen over the last couple of years.
We're very excited about the work that we're doing with it and how it's aligning to all the work that's happening in states.
It's very exciting.
And so we will be coming back to you all in March to bring you that.
And then I just wanted to bring up Kristen for some final thoughts and if you have any questions.
So now hopefully I'm preaching to the choir.
Students with disabilities, as we've all agreed, are general education students who receive special education.
And again, if UCB and our division sends something out that doesn't say that, please let us know because we're really trying hard to stay true to that.
And really, our mantra from this moment forward is really increasing opportunities for our students to be with their peers, having great access to the standards who are wonderful standards and frameworks in general education, and that we're making a concerted effort to work with our higher education partners around teacher training and research to practice.
So look forward for what's to come.
I'll see you back in five months.
Yes, thank you.
Oh, Board Member Burr.
Kristen, I know that you will do this and probably are already doing it, but I really encourage us to use the opportunity through the ESSA state plan to bring the IDEA and what we want on behalf of our students with disabilities to be consistent with
what the flexibility that's allowed in ESSA.
We got the first version of the plan yesterday, and I know there are gonna be lots of subsequent, and I didn't really see it in there, but maybe it is, so just, I really encourage you to make sure that we've got a real close match, and that we're pushing the feds as hard as we can to bring this group of students into alignment with all of our general education students.
agree more and I've been invited to go back with the team to DC.
So we'll be definitely having more conversations around then.
I was reading it as well and I see some opportunities there too.
And the other thing that's on the horizon and that ESSA does provide us the opportunity for when we're talking about graduation rates is that alternate diploma.
And so we do have some work groups, our community of practice out in the field who've started to talk about that.
So we'll be bringing that to to you guys.
in the future to talk about what potential there is for that, and I think there's a lot of potential there as well.
I also agree with Board Member Burr's recommendation, particularly as it relates not only to the multi-tiered systems of support, that needs to be part of what's written into the ESSA State Plan, particularly in Title I, but also the response to intervention, because a lot of people confuse the response to intervention as a special education program, and that's a general education program.
I think that we need to advocate for response and intervention to be part of our ESSA state plan as well.
And then, because I'm the liaison for the interstate compact concerning military dependents, I would really like to ask you and to ask your division
to consider attending the next state council meeting to talk with those folks about this, because when we have military dependents who leave California with an IEP, or military dependents who come to California and they have an IEP and need to get it implemented, there are some issues that need to be looked at and understood, and they are related to what's in that compact.
We'd be very happy to do that.
Board Member Ortiz-Lacombe.
Yeah, and to follow up just on a practical level with your second point, I know that even as an educator, it was such a hard process to navigate having my son transition from a regional center to a preschool to K-12 because there was no, very little conversations and guidance that I had available to me as a parent to make sure that my son had the services he needed as he made those transitions.
So if there is some guidance that could be provided and streamline the process so that parents who are not acquainted with the school system, I can't imagine what they do, because having a husband who's a teacher and myself being very acquainted, it was such a difficult process for us.
Thank you.
Having similar experiences, I also know, and I think the bottom line is that we want to indoctrinate and empower our parents to know that their kids belong from the beginning, and when you start someone else telling them they don't belong and sending them somewhere separate, that's where they become comfortable and feel like that is the trajectory that's expected.
So I think switching that will really help to shift the culture, and looking forward to some partnerships around that from you all.
Thanks.
Good.
Okay.
Is there any no?
If there's no more board member comments, public comment, we have a motion.
We have an action item here.
No public comment.
Okay.
We ready for a motion?
Board member Sandoval.
I'd like to move approval of the CD's recommendation to approve the executive summary.
Second.
We have a second.
Any further board discussion?
If not, all those raise your hands.
Thank you very much.
Okay, we're now going to move on to the waivers.
But while we collect, we're going to take a little bit of break till 1030 and then resume with the waivers so that we can find out who wants to speak on these.
So we have a quorum, so I think we'll begin the waiver items.
We have three items to hear.
So first I want to move the waiver consent items.
They are W1, W2, and W5 through W8.
Do I have a motion on those?
I would move the recommendation.
And I'll second.
Is there any public comment on those items?
Not on 1, 5, or 8.
Okay, we're going to hear three, four, and nine.
So okay, that's been moved and seconded on consent.
Those waivers, all those in favor, raise your hand.
Okay, that is approved.
Now we go on to waiver three.
And the department will present on these 349.
Go ahead.
First three individually.
Yeah.
Good morning, President Kirsten members.
I'm Karen Moore.
I'm the associate director of the school fiscal services division, and I'm going to present waiver three, which was
submitted by the Los Angeles Unified School District on behalf of City High Charter School.
This waiver would allow City High Charter School to receive full advance funding without recognition of a cap that's currently in statute.
So as background, for the months of July through January, school districts, county offices of education, and continuing charter schools receive advance funding through the principal apportionment process based on what they received in the last year and the number of students that they served.
there's a provision in education code that allows new and expanding charter schools to also receive advanced funding similar to what others also receive.
There is the provision of law though that caps the amount that an expanding charter school can receive at the level of ADA served in the prior year and the highest grade served in the prior year.
And so this would cap the amount that this charter school would receive.
So the waiver would allow them to receive full funding for all of the students that they are expected to serve.
Just as a side note, City High Charter served grade 9 last year.
They were expecting to serve grades 6 through 8 and grade 10.
This year, they're no longer serving grade 10.
So the funding that would be provided as a result of this waiver would just include grades 6 through 8.
So that's a change from what's in your waiver.
So just to wrap up.
Good.
We have some public comment on this item, I assume, or do we, on waiver?
Yes.
Yeah.
Public comment?
Not on three, no.
Okay.
No comment.
Somehow got pulled off.
Hearing no public comment, I'm ready for a motion.
On waiver three.
Move approval.
All right.
All those in favor, raise your hands.
OK, that approves waiver three.
Now we're on to waiver four.
Good morning, I'm Board President Kerr, Superintendent Torlakson, and members of the board.
I'm Cindy Chan, Director of the Charter Schools Division at the California Department of Education.
So waiver item four is a request by three school districts on behalf of their charter schools that are listed in detachment one to waive
language in the California Regulatory Code and regarding a timeline.
And so these charter schools, as all non-classroom based charter schools, have to submit a funding determination to the State Board, which usually comes in as a separate item.
And that would approve the level of funding and the timing of the funding, so how much and for how long.
for their non-classroom based ADA.
These three charter schools missed the very specific deadlines that are in the regulations, and so the funding determination cannot be heard by the Advisory Commission on Charter Schools, and we cannot bring the request to this board as well without the waiver because they are delinquent.
So this waiver would allow the charter schools to kind of get their foot in the door, we'd bring the funding determination request to the advisory commission, and then in a separate item at a subsequent board meeting, we would bring the funding determination to the state board, and at that time, you would make a decision on the level of funding and for how long the funding would be for.
So this one doesn't apportion funds, it allows that first step in the process for the charter schools.
Unfortunately, without approval of the waiver, it's all or nothing.
The charter schools receive zero money.
Okay, there is public comment on that.
Let's hear this.
Would Angela De Ramos and Ernie Silva please step forward?
Good morning, I'm Angela Dura-Ramos, I'm representing CTA, and CTA opposes Waiver 4 on the basis that it's very specific deadlines that have a very specific date requirement, so it's not an excuse for a waiver.
Thank you.
Hi, I'm Ernie Silva for Sciatech.
As you know, a charter school must go through the school district to do these waivers.
We can't come direct, but I'm here.
As you know, ours is a dropout recovery network.
What we've done historically has been classroom-based.
We've screwed up this year.
percentage tweaked over that, tripped over that 20%, and our staff missed the deadline.
So we remain committed to dropout recovery, we remain committed to serving the population, and we're asking that we be excused and allowed to proceed to be able to fund the work that we do with that population.
I'd be glad to, I'm not sure why it was pulled, so I'd be glad to answer any questions when you,
you have them.
If or when you have them.
Thank you.
We'll see if there's any questions.
Any board member discussion of this item.
Move approval.
Second.
Board discussion.
I'm hearing any all those in favor.
Raise your hands.
Okay These are approved.
Now we're on the waiver.
Nine
Good morning, President Cruz, members of the board.
I am Scott Kirby, Director of State Special Schools and Services Division, and we are hearing Waiver 10, a request to waive educational interpreter in Plumas Unified School District.
As you may know, educational interpreters shall be certified by the Registry of Interpreters for the Deaf.
In lieu of that, they also have the opportunity to pass a test of a score of 4.0 by the Educational Interpreter Performance Assessment, or the Educational Science Skills Evaluation, or the National Association for the Deaf.
Plumas Unified, this student at Plumas Unified has, they also have requested a waiver before.
Started back in 2012.
In August of 2012, Plumas Unified requested a waiver from this board for this educational interpreter for school year 2012-13.
The waiver was approved by the board with conditions.
That educational interpreter at that time scored 3.2 on the EIPA.
A 3.2 on the EIPA means 64% of the content is transferred from the teacher to the student.
In November 2013, Plumas approached the board one more time for another waiver for the same interpreter.
The waiver was approved with conditions.
In June 2013, that interpreter attempted the EIPA again and went from 3.2 to 3.3.
Now it's up to 68% of the information transferred from the teacher to the student.
In July 2014, this is the third request for waiver, Plumas approached the board and requested a waiver for the same interpreter.
The waiver was approved with conditions once again.
In May 2014, the interpreter attempted the EIPA again with the same score of 3.3.
For 2015-16, this past school year, the interpreter continued to provide interpreting services to the same student for a fourth year, but the district did not ask for a waiver for that school year.
Today, the Plumas is asking for a waiver for that same interpreter, for the same student, for the fourth time.
In this past November 15, the interpreter attempted a different test, the ESSE, a little different interpreting evaluation.
The interpreter received a score of 2.0 on expressive, which is 40% information that is transferred, and in receptive, a 3.4 score, which is 68% transferred to the student.
Our recommendation to the Board of Education that this waiver be denied.
Okay, some questions.
This is a rural school district and, you know, what are their options?
It said they wanted to send the child to the Fremont School for the Deaf.
I mean, it's way out there.
I've been there.
Their options are limited.
This is the only student in the school district.
and attends a middle school high school.
That middle school high school has about 150 students with that one child with an educational interpreter that follows that student from class to class to class.
Plumas has identified or has provided some accommodations to the interpreter and the student
and they traveled to a neighboring school district where there are other students that are deaf and hard of hearing.
And yes, you are correct, there was a recommendation to the parent and a referral to the California School for the Deaf in Fremont a couple years ago, and the parent did not have any interest in having their child attend the California School for the Deaf in Fremont.
Okay, any board member further board member discussion.
We will have a public comment on this.
Do we have any public comment on this?
No.
Yeah, I know.
Board member Sandoval next.
Yeah.
I have just a few questions.
We received a letter dated October 26th from the school district, and my question to you is, is there any new information in this letter, especially regarding the proposed training plan for the interpreter that wasn't in your original analysis of the item?
There is no new training for the interpreter.
The original training consisted of a mentor for 36 hours a year, and that happened two consecutive years with no significant change in this interpreter's score from a 3.2 to a 3.3.
What they have differently is cited in the letter and that they are now providing some of this cross over to another district where there are other students that are deaf and hard of hearing and there are staff that also communicate in sign language.
That attempt was twofold, as I mentioned earlier.
It provides that interpreter to gain some high-level interpreting skills or ASL skills, and also allows that student to interact in an environment in his or her language of ASL.
That's the only difference.
And then just a couple of follow-up questions.
vote to approve your recommendation to deny the waiver, and the district is responsible for hiring a qualified interpreter to serve the students' needs, does this particular interpreter continue services until that new interpreter is hired?
No.
Okay, so what happens to the student in that case?
No, I'm sorry.
What happens to the student, if we do deny the waiver today, then what happens to the student services tomorrow?
That's an unfortunate dilemma presented to the board, that here in this rural area called Plumas, they have one interpreter, one educational interpreter, and that one educational interpreter is functioning at a 3.2, 3.3 level.
The question is, do we allow that interpreter to continue at that level, or do we deny that person providing that service, and therein leaves no interpreter?
I share that dilemma and that frustration as well.
In the past, I'm sorry, in the past during some of the calls when this has come up, I think you've said or someone has said that one of the options is the district will be found out of compliance as part of their special ed monitoring.
They would keep the interpreter on and then they would be found out of compliance and then they have to come up with a new compliance plan.
Is that one of the?
That's correct.
or sometimes what happens, I think the district reclassifies the interpreter.
That's also correct.
I didn't want to really emphasize that point, but it's not uncommon that we do have evidence or we do have information that districts, when they cannot have or find an interpreter that's qualified at a 4.0 level, they just simply change the classification from educational interpreter to instructional assistant.
Oh, by the way, they're providing some interpreting services to that individual student.
What technical assistance or support could your division offer this district in making sure that the student receives the best possible services?
Good question.
As I was reviewing this case, I was thinking over and over again in my head about how the California School for the Deaf has a resource center.
and how that resource center can make a contact with Plumas Unified and offer their services and how to give some support to the student and the interpreter.
And so I will make a referral to the California School for the Deaf Resource Center to reach out to Plumas Unified and see if we can, if that resource center can provide additional accommodation, support, training,
for both the interpreter and for the students' teachers.
Do we have any information about the educational progress of the student?
In the letter?
In the October 26th letter, they cited that the student is far below at grade level in reading, but at grade level or doing very well in math.
But we understand, also cited in the October 26th letter, the student was identified mentally retarded in the old language, the new language, intellectually disabled, for many years.
And then finally they discovered, no,
The student's not mentally retarded, the student is deaf.
They finally referred the student to an audiologist, and the audiologist fitted the student with a hearing aid, and the student start acquiring language.
But at that time, the student had already been delayed in language five or six years, and now the student is starting to build that language base and language development.
We're number rocker.
Okay, so, um.
There's several issues here with this waiver that have been some of the reasons why the board has continued to approve the waiver.
And the most important factor for me has been that the district seems to have had some limited options.
And so I'm going to try to say the next sentence carefully, and I'm going to ask if there's any representatives from the district either listening to this or who are here in the room
I'm going to ask for forgiveness, but this needs to be said.
I think that there are some issues, especially when it comes to dealing with students who have speech and audiology issues.
There are some very significant mistakes that are often made in providing those services, and one is the assumption that there's a learning disability rather than a speech and audiology
students.
And so I think it's important that we address this issue related to how the services are provided to the student.
The fact is, however, in identifying that the student is hat is not meeting standards is not making the progress that's expected toward proficiency.
Is it because the student is not learning or because the student is not being given full and appropriate
It's fine if the district chooses, for purposes of compliance and the reporting they have to do, to reclassify this individual so that they are, instead of being an interpreter, they're merely an instructional aid, but it doesn't change the obligation the district has to ensure full access for that student, and it's not being addressed.
the district is choosing to use the waiver process and still failing to address that requirement.
So while I know we are concerned about whether or not the student is receiving interpretive services, the student is not being well served by this interpreter.
And I think of the two issues, that is the more important because this student is getting older.
This student is matriculating.
At some point, this student is supposed to try to graduate.
And we're supposed to be guaranteeing this student and this student's parents that he will be college and career ready.
As long as we allow the student to be served by someone who is giving them information that is less than 70% of the content that's being presented to that student, the content's not going to get easier.
The expected cognitive load and the work that the student is supposed to demonstrate proficiency for is not going to get easier, and the ability of this interpreter
clearly is not going to improve.
Now we have in this state a state syllabi literacy, and I believe American Sign Language is included as one of the languages that students can earn a state syllabi literacy in.
We have high school students graduating with that state syllabi literacy in American Sign Language who have better interpretive skills than this professional.
We need to think about that.
Well, it seems to me pretty clear that, you know, approving this waiver is not a good idea.
So why don't we move to a motion and then the department can come back with some kind of plan to deal with this.
But I don't think we should give him a waiver personally.
Go ahead, Board Member Burke.
Sorry, but I just want to clarify what you said, because it seems different than what the district wrote in their letter.
The district says the student is a 13-year-old girl, normal cognitive ability.
When she arrived in our district, she had no language, was labeled the way you described it.
After a few weeks, she was tested by an audiologist, and then they, I thought you said there were several years that went by before she was?
Before she was?
Oh, was that in a prior district?
Is that what you?
No, no, they're describing what has happened in their district.
After IEP was changed to DEF.
She arrived with an IEP that said one thing.
One thing, and then the IEP was changed to another thing.
Well, so anyway, I just encourage everybody to read the letter from the district about what they have tried to do.
And it sounds like they don't have entirely cooperative parents who were not interested in this referral.
And for those of you who have never been to Chester, I'm not, I think Nikki was kind of pursuing this line of questioning.
I don't know that denying this and denying services to the student is also the way to go.
And the district is describing an alternative plan that they're trying to do, matching up with this other middle school that is close by.
So again, this is a real dilemma.
Well, in the best of all worlds, I agree with you, Patricia, that we want to have the most highly capable people available.
But if this is the only person in this county
that has the ability to provide services and has been providing services to the student who's now at grade level in math.
I think we just have to think really carefully about it because otherwise I don't know what they do.
So what I'm trying to glean out of this is some kind of tweener here where
I'm not entirely sure what the motion would be, but if we could let them try their new approach, and at the same time, you could put into place what your suggestion for outreach and training.
And then reassess this, like in four to six months.
So it's not leave him with nothing.
but it's something where increased intervention, both by CDE and by the school, and then we look at it again.
that.
Well, just let me interject on that.
I thought that you were saying that they would just take the person they had and to designate them as an aid.
So it's being posed here as an all or nothing.
Is that no, I'm not suggesting that's what plumas will do.
What I mentioned is that that has been a past practice by other districts.
When a an interpreter cannot be
qualified, then they simply change the classification.
I'm not, I cannot suggest that's what Plumas will do.
Board member Strauss.
So on the board item, so it's on the attachment, it's on page 790 of the pdf one, but anyway it's lists
that if we would consider approval, there are two conditions we could include.
One is that they give her weekly one-on-one mentorship by a qualified interpreter with an individualized professional development plan with goals and objectives.
that weekly videotaping of her in the classroom with weekly telephone, Skype, FaceTime meetings with her mentor with feedback, and that they give CDE the logs documenting the weekly mentoring spent by Ms.
Metzger and her mentor, and that by June of 2017, they give CDE a new assessment score for Ms.
Metzger.
That's a pretty intense intervention.
It still gives the student
ongoing support.
I looked on, this is a really isolated area, really small, and so I think there's been some thought that if we didn't want to pull the support completely, we would have an intensive intervention with a short-term turnaround.
It's the rest of the school year with a decision at that point.
So I just wanted to comment on that.
That's in the item that might be helpful to the discussion for the Board.
Board Member Rock.
Okay, this situation has been going on in this district for more than one year.
And so each time on the conditions, the focus has been to do the professional development to improve
her score on the assessment.
What concerns me is that the professional development, while it focuses on improving her proficiency as an instructor, there's been no focus on improving her proficiency in American Sign Language.
So mentoring is nice.
I was a mentor teacher, but that did not mean the people I mentored understood English as a subject any better.
So I need to understand why there's no requirement in all of this time for this person to have taken a course in American Sign Language.
I mean, if you want to, mentoring is a very important role.
I mean, it would be a mistake for us to sit here as this body and say professional development has no place.
But the other part of professional development is professional training.
And so I have to tell you, I haven't seen that in any of the previous waivers we've looked at, any requirement for actual professional training.
And so the fact that they're coming back with a plan where they've added something else to the work for mentoring and monitoring and overseeing her, the goal is still to change her performance on the assessment itself, not to actually improve her skills in using American Sign Language.
So I'm fine if you want to do a tweener,
as long as she has to take and pass a university-level course or at the community college or something that actually requires her to improve her skill set in using American Sign Language and understanding it herself, because the reason why she's not improving on the test
is not because the district has not been helpful and not because the district hasn't intervened, but if the sole focus is to maintain her certification as an interpreter and not to make her a better interpreter because she can use sign language better, the problem will not be corrected.
Okay, I think we've...
discussed this?
You have a comment?
She has received mentoring in 1213 and 1314.
She received 35 hours in 1213 by a certified interpreter and 35 hours of mentoring and support by a certified interpreter in 1314.
So let's try a motion and then see where we go.
One question.
How far away is the other school with other students who sign?
90 minutes.
Yeah.
Over over two lane roads would probably weave around a lot if it's a Feather River.
And my understanding is they only do that once or twice a month.
maybe more frequently might help.
Well, because of the travel, she misses some of her core courses back in her home.
We don't have anyone from the district here, do we, to speak on?
No.
Okay, I appreciate the conversation turning away from the adult to the student and how we can best support the student.
And if it's a tweener, something along those lines, I would go for that.
Well, do we have a motion?
Yeah, well, what I'd like to ask is,
If we approve the CDE's recommendation, if we could amend it to ensure that the student continues to receive services at school, can we add that in there?
approved to deny the waiver with under the conditions, well, it's.
That's approving the waiver with the conditions.
No, because you don't want that person.
You want to deny her waiver, but you want somebody to continue serving the student.
Basically, the way that the recommendation is written is that the CD is recommending denial of the waiver.
request and also recommends that we direct the school district to hire a qualified educational interpreter to provide services to their students.
Okay, so I that I'm interested in supporting that motion.
However, my biggest concern is the student going without any services, so it's
Is there a way to amend that motion so that it continues some services for this student while this search doesn't student under law have the right to services?
Do we have the district's out of compliance?
They have to pass a motion every time.
Isn't that what you're supposed to be doing?
Yes, sir.
Yeah.
So
Okay, so if we accept the recommendation, if we vote on that, the student will still be receiving services while the search is conducted for a qualified interpreter.
The student's IEP requires that the student receive services for an interpreter.
Okay.
Okay, then I move to approve the CD's recommendation to deny the waiver.
I'll second.
Okay.
All those in favor, raise your hands.
Okay, does that carry?
Keep them up.
One, two, three, four, five, six.
It carries.
Okay, and are you guys no votes?
I'm a no vote.
Okay.
All right.
Three noes.
Put up your hands for noes.
Okay.
She's not voting.
Oh, you're abstaining.
So, will you put up your hands for noes, please?
And then, who is abstaining?
Okay.
Thank you.
That ends that item.
And since we put items 11 through 17, we did those yesterday.
That's our proposed consent.
We're now ready for item 18.
a public hearing on the petition for the establishment of a charter school under the oversight of S B. E. Solarity in Los Angeles Unified.
So first of all, the department will present and then I'll open the public hearing.
Uh, then we'll have the department present.
We'll have board member technical questions of the department, then the public hearing and then more discussion.
Hello again, Cindy Chan, Director of Charter Schools Division at the California Department of Education.
So the next three items, as President Cruz said, are public hearings.
Each request is to establish a new charter school.
Each were denied by a local school district and denied, again, on appeal to a county board of education.
So I'll begin with item 18, which is an appeal by Celerity Himalaya Charter School to establish a new charter school, which was denied by the Los Angeles Unified School District and the Los Angeles County Board of Education.
The city received the Celerity Himalaya appeal on August 1st, 2016, and based on a review of the petition documents and information submitted, the department is recommending that the State Board hold a public hearing and thereafter approve, with two conditions and 11 technical amendments, the request to establish Celerity Himalaya under the oversight of the State Board for a five-year term, effective July 1, 2016, through June 30th, 2021.
So as part of our recommendation for approval, we are also recommending the two following conditions, and the first one's very long.
And there won't be a point of context, but I will later down in my presentation explain, which will, I think, support what we're saying in this condition.
Celerity Educational Group may only continue to contract with Celerity Global Development for goods and or services.
If Solarity Educational Group and Solarity Global Development agree to timely respond to all California Department of Education inquiries into Solarity Educational Group's and Solarity Global Development's operations, including but not limited to,
management, fiscal, personnel, procurement, facilities operations, facilities financing, and programmatic services in accordance with Education Code section 47604.3, which is related to responding to inquiries made by the California Department of Education.
and fully cooperate with any investigation into their operations conducted pursuant to Education Code Section 47604.4.
The second condition is that Celerity Helmaya must adhere to the terms and conditions as noted in Attachment 1 of the item, which is the State Board of Education standard conditions on opening an operation.
The Advisory Commission on Charter Schools considered the Celerity-Jamalia petition at its October 4th meeting and voted to recommend that the State Board approve the charter petition with the CDE's recommended conditions and 11 technical amendments.
The motion passed with a vote of five to one.
Celerity Homalia is proposing to serve approximately 390 pupils in transitional kindergarten through grade five in year one, expanding to 565 pupils in TK through grade eight.
The charter school proposes to offer a site-based matriculation setting with a commitment to increasing the achievement of at-risk pupils from communities in need within LAUSD.
So as part of a review of a charter petition, we must determine whether the petition sufficiently meets the required statutory criteria, and that includes, but not limited to, these three kind of main areas that we always focus on.
The charter school presents a sound educational program, the petitioners are able to successfully implement the intended program, and the petition contains reasonably comprehensive descriptions of the required elements.
A lack of sufficiency in one or more area may form the basis for a finding of fact supporting grounds for a denial.
Based on review of the Celerity Hamalia petition documents, we find the petition adequately describes the educational program and addresses how it will serve Celerity Hamalia's target student population with the addition of our recommended technical amendments.
We also find that the petition provides an adequate description of the multiple required elements, noting that we have identified some that would require a technical amendment.
That leaves the third criterion, petitioner's ability to successfully implement the program.
For this particular criterion,
The regulations contain a number of factors that must be considered.
One of these factors is the financial plan.
We have reviewed the petitioner's multi-year budget, and as we typically do, we review the petitioner's budget and then we would make any adjustments we feel are necessary based on our typically more conservative approach for a new charter school.
After applying our adjustments to various revenue and expenditure categories, we find the plan to be reasonably sufficient to support the intended program.
However, we find that the petition presents a governance structure that may compromise the petitioner's ability to implement the program.
So now I'll just walk you through the governance structure, which hopefully will help to explain our concerns and that those are the basis for the recommended condition.
So keep in mind that the Solarity organization currently exists.
It operates seven active charter schools.
All seven have the same governance structure.
So what I'm about to describe to you is the current practice of the organization.
So I'll start with Solarity Educational Group, and I'll refer to that as CEG.
The petition indicates that Solarity Himalaya will be operated by CEG, which is a non-profit public benefit corporation.
The affairs of the Charter School will be managed and its powers exercised under the ultimate jurisdiction of CEG's Board of Trustees.
The CEG Board of Trustees shall have ultimate responsibility for the operation and activities of the Charter School.
Some of their major roles and responsibilities include establishing and approving all major educational and operational policies, approving all major contracts, approving the annual budget for the charter school and overseeing the fiscal affairs, meeting corporate requirements, and selecting and evaluating the administrative staff.
To note, current law does allow charter schools to elect to operate as or be operated by a non-profit public benefit corporation.
We find that this type of governance structure that I described to be not uncommon for non-profit public benefit corporations such as charter management organizations that operate more than one charter school.
However, kind of moving forward, there's another layer to the charter school's governance structure.
Celerity Global Development, which I'll refer to as GLOBAL.
The charter school's governing bylaws indicate that GLOBAL, another separate non-profit public benefit corporation, shall serve as the sole statutory member of CEG.
As sole statutory member, Global's rights include the right to vote on approving the elected CEG trustees, removal of elected trustees, approving the disposition of all or substantially all of CEG's assets, approving any merger, and any election to dissolve the CEG.
We find that this type of governance structure that involves a sole statutory, a sole member, that it does exist in other charter schools.
We believe it's not as common as the prior example.
And yet, there's another layer that I'd like to explain and add on that is outlined in the petition.
So there is another relationship between CEG and Global, aside from the statutory member.
In addition to Global's role as sole statutory member of CEG, CEG contracts with Global for various services for all of the charter schools it oversees, which would include Solarity Himalaya.
These services include but are not limited to management, staff development, supervisory oversight, fiscal services, human resources, procurement, information technology, and facilities operations and financing.
as Global serves as a sole statutory member of CEG and is also a contracted vendor of CEG.
The CDE is concerned that the control this affords one of CEG's primary vendors over its board of trustees presents the potential for a conflict of interest that puts at risk the charter school's future operational health.
This was also a concern noted by both LAUSD and LACOE in their review of the charter petition.
We believe that our recommended condition that I read to you earlier is prudent, given the unique relationship of the Charter School, the CEG Board of Trustees, and Global, serving as both sole statutory member and contracted vendor of CEG.
So I can answer any questions.
That concludes my presentation.
The Solarity petitioners here and representatives from LACO and possibly LAOSD are here as well to present to the Board.
Thank you.
Board member questions.
I do have some questions, but I'm wondering if we should let them.
Yeah, we can wait after that.
Usually this is sometimes for technical hearing none.
All right.
I will open the public hearing and first we'll have 10 minutes for each side.
The first will take the side that supports the CED recommendation for the State Board of Education to approve the charter.
You have 10 minutes.
Pardon the interruption.
It's all connected.
Good morning.
My name is Nadia Shaik.
I am Director of School Services for Solarity Educational Group.
Together with the Director of Pupil Services and our CEO, I am proud and excited to be speaking before you today to give you an overview of our schools, our students, and our programs, as well as to address some of the technical revisions and conditions requested by the CDE staff.
Solarity Charter Schools operate on the firm belief that holding the highest expectations and providing an engaging and challenging curriculum, coupled with bringing students cultures and backgrounds, results in students from traditionally underserved and underperforming areas performing at the highest levels.
And we have seen that mission become a reality in the past 11 years since our first school opened in 2005.
We currently have seven schools in Los Angeles serving over 3,500 students.
All of our schools serve at-risk youth in traditionally underserved areas.
Our schools are either already WASC accredited or are undergoing the initial accreditation process currently, and four of the seven schools are California Distinguished Schools.
Celerity Himalaya's population will mirror those of the surrounding schools.
Approximately 100% of our community's students qualify for the free and reduced lunch program, and an average of 41% of students from the elementary and middle schools are English learners.
The community is mostly Latino and African American.
We would like to share with you a day in the life of a Celerity scholar.
Each day, Remar looks forward to learning in class, as well as seeing all of his friends at school.
Celerity staff makes sure to build relationships with families to bridge the connection between home and school.
Let's see what it's like inside the classroom.
The classes at Celerity are designed to be rigorous and differentiated to meet the needs of everyone in the class.
Celerity schools place a strong emphasis on integrating technology into the classroom to bridge the technological divide.
Each student has their own laptop to work with.
Lessons are delivered on high-definition projectors, and students use online interactive programs.
One of the most distinguishing features of a Celerity school is its robust performing arts program, with all students learning dancing, acting, singing, and playing instruments.
Now Raymar is going over information for an upcoming project.
The teachers are trained in Lauren Resnick's principles of learning and give students clear expectations for what is required on projects to make sure no student feels lost or left behind.
Celerity builds a culture that understanding where you need help and how to get that help is the mark of a scholar.
And that being intelligent is something you do, not something you are.
Celerity students receive conflict resolution training through the model of the Celerity Peace Tree, which teaches them the language and structure to resolve conflicts on their own under the guidance of the adults on campus.
Students feel welcome and are encouraged to be the best students they can be.
Raymar looks forward to his future and knows that he is developing the skills necessary to achieve his future dreams.
He looks forward to continuing his journey when he returns tomorrow.
Solarity Himalaya will be a transitional kinder through eighth grade program.
The transitional kindergarten program is an educational opportunity for children who turn five between September 2nd and December 2nd to participate in Solarity's first year of a two-year kindergarten program that uses age and developmentally appropriate modified kindergarten academic curriculum that includes social, emotional, and cognitive outcomes and benchmarks.
Our instructional program is research-based and tailored to this diverse population of students.
We follow Lauren Resnick's principles of learning, the idea that being smart isn't something you are, but it's something you do.
Teachers have clear expectations through rubrics to students that outline clearly what it takes to get the grade.
Students set goals for themselves on how they want to do on upcoming benchmarks and what specific steps they're going to take to get there, and we celebrate their accomplishments when they reach them.
The second core tenet is culturally responsive and relevant pedagogy.
The idea that as teachers, we should bring students' cultures and backgrounds and identities into the educational program.
As you walk through our classrooms, you will see evidence of call and response, of using Spanish cognates in lessons, and of students bringing in artifacts from home that connect to the lesson.
The third core tenant of our instructional program is project-based learning.
Students take part in interdisciplinary projects that have a real-world connection to their communities while building a local and a global consciousness.
Good morning, Celeste Adeter, Director of Pupil Services for Solarity Schools.
This doesn't go much shorter than that.
Solarity uses multiple formative, thank you, and summative measures to identify low achievement, such as annual district benchmarks, state assessments, school-wide writing exams, CELT scores, and teacher report cards to make sure the students receive further development to demonstrate skills and knowledge required for future coursework.
Solarity Hamalia will use a variety of strategies to stretch and rapidly grow the skills and abilities of its highest achieving students, so they do not become bored or complacent, but instead continue to feel challenged and supported.
This includes in-class individual tutoring, and during the expanded learning program, they'll have access to learning software and materials designed for their mastery level, and opportunities to participate in extended classes or lessons.
Students who perform below Himalaya's predetermined acceptable levels will receive a mix of intervention services.
These services will include in-class, individual, and small group tutoring by classroom teachers before, during, or after school, as well as before or after school tutoring during the expanded learning block in one-on-one or in small group settings.
All of our teachers in grades TK through eighth grade inclusive hold multiple subject teaching credentials with EL certifications.
Teachers will regularly examine student work samples at grade-level meetings to ensure that students are mastering grade-level standards.
Weekly assessment data will be reviewed with the curriculum specialist and the teachers to identify students who are not meeting standards.
Intervention strategies and follow-up testing is planned with the curriculum specialist and the teacher to ensure academic growth of students.
For internal candidates wishing to advance to a leadership position, a 360-degree evaluation system is utilized in which Solarity will use feedback from each applicant's subordinates, peers, and supervisors in the decision-making process.
Solarity's financial plans incorporate all stakeholders in the development and revision process.
Real-time budgetary comparisons are available to decision-makers at all levels in order to address and respond to any changes in the organization's needs.
Good morning.
My name is Grace Canada, and I am the Chief Executive Officer for Solarity Educational Group.
I'm grateful for the opportunity to stand before you today.
The organization is governed by a five-member nonprofit board of directors with experience in areas such as legal, business, finance, public relations, entrepreneurship, human resources, and leadership.
The board's major role and responsibilities include, but are not limited to, establishing and approving all major educational and operational policies, approving all major contracts, approving the charter school's annual budget, overseeing the charter school's fiscal affairs, meeting corporate requirements, and selecting and evaluating the chief executive officer.
Celerity Rolas and Celerity Himalaya Charter Schools will be operated by CEG, Celerity Educational Group.
CEG is an independent, non-profit charter management organization that opened and currently operates seven exceptionally high-quality, high-performing public charter schools within the Los Angeles metropolitan area and Compton.
CEG provides services to all of its CEG schools, which reduces operational costs for the individual schools.
CEG also contracts with Global for some of those services, as well as for some miscellaneous services.
The CEG board has sole discretion over granting or terminating those contracts.
Global is a separate nonprofit entity created in 2012 to support the CEG schools and the CEG instructional model, such as trademarking the celerity name and protecting its intellectual property,
building a leadership development system, and doing some other functions unrelated to the CEG schools, like charity work.
In addition, Global is the sole statutory member of CEG.
The rights of Global as the sole member of CEG are limited to, one, the right to approve CEG's elected directors, two, the right to approve a decision by the CEG board to dispose of all or substantially all the corporate assets, and three, the right to approve a decision by the CEG board to merge or dissolve the corporation.
These provisions give global corporate rights as to the CEG corporation, but they do not give global any rights to the school's operations, governance, or decisions.
Those rights are retained by the CEG board.
Yeah, your 10 minutes is up, so we'll have to close this.
On behalf of the CEG Board of Directors, I humbly request that you accept the staff report and recommendations for the establishment of Celerity Himalaya.
Thank you.
Okay, we'll now have 10 minutes for the opponents of the CDE recommendation that the State Board approve the charter with conditions.
Good morning, Board President Kirst, Superintendent Torlakson, members of the board.
My name is Robert Perry.
I am from the Charter Schools Division of the Los Angeles Unified School District, and I have with me today from the Office of the General Counsel, Devorah Rivera-Reed.
Good morning.
We've come here today representing LAUSD to bring before the board facts for your consideration related to the two celerity items on the agenda.
Our main concerns are around the persistent lack of transparency which has impinged upon the district's ability to fully execute its statutory charge to oversee charter schools which it authorizes.
This lack of transparency is evident in two overarching areas, fiscal management and governance.
The petitioner operates under the name of Solarity Education Group, and although it is the nonprofit corporation legally responsible for operating its own charter schools, there are other separate but affiliated legal entities that participate in the operation of the same charter schools.
For example, Solarity Global Development
provides day-to-day management and administrative support to petitioners' charter schools according to their affiliation agreement.
That agreement specifically states that Global does not comply with the Charter Schools Act nor Public Records Act.
This is concerning since the Charter Schools Division has identified potential conflicts of interest and the commingling of financial transactions between Celerity Education Group
and Global, and its other separate but affiliated legal entities, including a one-time transfer of over $2 million from two separate accounts from Solarity Education Group to Global without appropriate documentation.
Through ongoing oversight, LAUSD Charter Schools Division's fiscal team has determined that the organization has demonstrated that it has insufficient controls and policies to address potential misuse of public funds.
When petitioner's credit card statements were reviewed, district staff identified purchases that were either redacted or appeared to be inappropriately used for non-educational purposes.
In response to staff's concerns, petitioners stated that many of the questioned charges did not belong to Celerity Education Group and were incurred by one of their affiliated organizations.
The district has discovered that petitioner loans funds between its current charter schools without appropriate documentation or adequate explanation.
This is particularly concerning since petitioner operates multiple charter schools within and outside of California.
The district has concerns and other potential authorizers should have concerns when it cannot verify through appropriate oversight that all public funds are being used for an educational purpose as they were intended to be.
The organizational structure, including but not limited to the administration and leadership of Solarity Education Group and its affiliated organizations, remains unclear.
While CEG changed chief executive officers in the past two years, staff notes that the prior CEO now leads Solarity Global, the sole statutory member of Solarity Education Group, and active contracts remain between the two organizations, all of which require further review and have not been presented always as requested.
Although the district acknowledges that CEG has reached out to LAUSD after the board denied two renewal petitions last month and is expressing a willingness to compromise for the sake of transparency, it is important to note that the district has been, since 2013, issuing notices to CURE
and this long-standing pattern of insufficient responses and remaining unanswered questions is not enough at this point to approve two new charter schools operated by this network.
Finally, it is important to note that Solarity's two other charter schools have a specific benchmark that the organization consistently respond to reasonable requests from the authorizer in a timely manner.
This benchmark has been in place since last year, and in spite of the benchmark, Celerity has continued in its pattern of insufficient responses, which impacts the district's ability to effectively carry out its oversight functions.
Thank you very much.
Good morning.
I'm Dina Wilson, and with me is April Mitchell, and we're here representing the Los Angeles County Office of Education.
The county board denied the petitions for both Celerity and Himalaya in June of 2016.
And as stated before, because the similarities in the petition, they're almost identical with the exception of the proposed location, the findings that we present here are applicable to both petitions.
We'll focus on the reasons for denial, which are listed on the screen.
Both LAUSD's board and the county board met this requirement denying the petitions with written findings supporting subsections B2 and B5.
In fact, several of the written findings in the CDE's report mirror those found at the local and county level.
And all three reports of findings contain substantial grounds for denying these charters.
Under subsection B-2, the district, county, and CDE have determined that the petitioners are demonstrably unlikely to successfully implement the charter.
The California Code of Regulations provides four indicators in making this determination, and the county board found that all four indicators were present.
Relating to schools operated by CEG, there have been two schools over the past several years that have been closed for reasons within the petitioner's control.
We will talk about X's Clothing later.
However, I'd like to focus on Celerity Sirius.
Celerity Sirius was a school that was authorized by the Los Angeles County Board, and the school closed in June 2016.
The school closed this past June after CEG chose not to accept the conditions of authorization that were set forth by the county board.
The specific condition proposed by CDE is nearly identical to the condition proposed by our board, including an agreement to timely respond to the authorizer's request for information.
CEG sent a letter to LACO after the county board had offered renewal subject to this condition.
The letter specifically states that they do not believe the law allows for conditional approvals, and further, that they did not agree to the condition.
One reason given was that the condition involved a third party, global, and therefore, they were unable to meet the condition.
This same statement is reiterated in CEG's response to the county findings that was included in their appeal to this board.
It is unclear how CEG would now be able to meet this same condition.
In addition to these items, LACOE shares in LAUSD's concerns about the organization's finance, operations, and governance.
They have demonstrated a history of lacking transparency and cooperating with authorizers.
They have failed to respond to district requests and even submitted with these petitions a set of bylaws that are not current and do not reflect the current organizational structure.
After several meetings between CEG and LACO, we were still given incorrect information regarding the sole statutory membership, and we were told it was just a vendor.
I'll turn it over to April Mitchell to discuss some of the financial findings related to CEG.
Thank you.
Both L.A.
Unified School District and the County Board reports illustrates concerns about the fiscal history of C.E.G.
and have identified weaknesses in their fiscal policies and practices of C.E.G.
schools.
The petitioner demonstrates a lack of adequate internal controls in the areas and a check approvals between July
From 2015 to September 2015, the CEO of CEG signed 47 checks totaling $1.8 million after she resigned from CEG in April of 2015.
Ten of those checks, totaling 1.2, were written to Global and other affiliated companies to Global.
The selection of vendors, Global receives and reviews all of CEG bids for services during the last two years.
Several global operated companies were awarded contracts, i.e., Solarity Contracting Services, Insured, Iran International Academy, and Solarity Development LLC.
Credit card policy allows for the CEO to authorize his or her own travel related to purchases, and there's many other deficiencies that we have within our report.
Also, there's been a history of interdepartmental borrowing, which has taken place in the absence of a formal policy or clear documentation to protect the schools and its students for whom funds are generated.
At the time of our review of CED's financials, it indicated that the organization's interdepartmental borrowing of $5.9 million in funds.
10 minutes is up.
Can you just wrap up quickly?
There's several others, and basically, I will, when I get to the other report, I will talk about the annual audits and the transfer of assets.
Okay, thank you.
But we want you to know that there are two authorizers here that have multiple years of experience working with CEG and its schools, and we're here to answer any of your questions.
Yeah.
Okay, I now declare the public hearing closed, and so we're ready for board member discussion.
And you have board member discussion.
Do you want to go to public comment or you want to go to discussion?
Yeah, this is a little technical, so we may want to ask some questions.
This may be a question either for L. A. U. S. D. Or the county.
But I'm trying to understand if they have seven schools in operation right now.
Who is the charter authorizer for those seven schools?
There are six with us in L. A. Unified member of our
And the other one?
The other one is?
It's with Compton.
Okay, thank you.
Board Member Ortiz-Lacon.
The governance structure is a little confusing to me, as I understand it, because there's a global company, and then there's the CEG, which is the non-profit.
I do know that a lot of community-based organizations are non-profits.
Then, you know, from that merges a charter school.
I'm acquainted with that, but I wasn't acquainted with that other level.
You authorized six, you recently revoked two, so you have four.
We non-renewed two.
Okay, non-renewed two.
When you authorized the six, did they have the same governance structure, and did that not give you pause at that point?
Was there something different that allowed the district to essentially approve six charter schools?
The bylaws that were presented to us at that time did not reflect this governance structure.
Even when the last two were presented to us, the governance structure was already in place, and the bylaws that reflected this governance structure were not presented with the last two renewals.
I would say that's true at the county as well.
We had learned about Global as a contractor as they were using it as a vendor, and knew that it was associated with Celerity Educational Group.
We had meetings beginning in 2014 with the former CEO and the current CEO, and we were told over and over again that there was no relationship, it was a vendor.
Even as late as December of 2015 when I inquired with the current CEO what are the,
what are current bylaws, we were given February 2012 bylaws, when it was April in 2012 where they changed these bylaws, giving global this power and also transferring assets, and that was not, I guess, disclosed, which is part of our MOU to make sure that they disclose that, and they continue to conceal that information.
We requested the names of board members and were not given that information prior to the denial of the two renewals.
And the next week we were given that information.
Can I continue?
Just for the sake of clarity in my head.
So we have Global has a board.
CEG has a board.
Global appoints the board for CEG.
CEG approves, and I hear like no, so we'll have them also respond.
CEG approves the contracts for vendors, which may include Global.
It doesn't seem like at the school level, it seems like academic performance is pretty solid, so that's not the concern.
But for me, I have to look at it holistically.
So when we're talking right now, yesterday we talked a lot about LCAP templates and having community stakeholder input and transparency.
Each of these schools is their own LEA, correct?
So how does that process look?
And maybe that's a question for them, because I'm interested in knowing, it's great that the academic performance is happening for Latino and African American students, which is 100% of your student population, but what about their parents, and to what extent are they engaged in the decisions that are made at the local level with something that impacts their students' education directly?
So if we could have them answer that question.
Thank you, so the question was the involvement of the parents in decisions of the site at the school, for the LCAP template, yes.
So we meet with parents in the LCAP process as the school develops it.
They meet with parents regularly.
They have monthly meetings with parents for parent meetings.
Monthly meetings they meet in our school site council, our DLAC.
and they share progress towards the LCAP.
We take parent surveys for input, include those surveys in the LCAP, and present back out to parents.
So they're involved throughout the year in the process.
And who approves it?
CEG or Global?
No, CEG.
CEG.
Okay, can I ask a question about the co-mingling?
Because I have experience working with CBOs and also with
charter management organizations and really great schools have been closed down because of the commingling.
That tends to be a practice that I'm not sure if it's not properly, charter school leaders are not properly guided in that sense, but the commingling for me gave me a lot of pause because one school in the district couldn't give money to another school in the district.
So I'm wondering how that looks and how that practice was identified and what Celerity has to say about that practice.
So are you asking Solarity up?
I'm asking both.
Because they identified the commingling, and I don't know at what point that happened, and then I don't know if Solarity agrees that there has been commingling of funds.
Kendall Turner, CFO of Solarity Educational Group.
Pardon, I couldn't hear you.
My name is Kendall Turner, senior of Solarity.
So it's not a commingling of funds.
What happened is we have elected to use one bank account to issue checks to vendors.
With seven schools, they sometimes use the same vendors.
The majority of them use the same vendors.
So what it appears for the district is that we're transferring.
What we do is we
We put all of the expenses on each individual book, so you can see individual checks that were written on the behalf of every school.
But in order to kind of reduce the amount of checks that are going to a vendor, so not sending seven checks to a vendor, we'll send one check to a vendor for any expenses that are incurred on the behalf of the schools.
Okay.
Confused.
Okay, sorry.
So there is one, again, there's one general operating account.
Again, so if, for instance, the schools all have the same custodial company, so all of the expenses are recorded.
So individually on the school's books, there's no co-mink.
The funds, the actual cash, is going out in one check.
And you also asked LA Unified to respond to this?
Yes.
Our fiscal team routinely, as a part of oversight, requests credit card statements.
We requested credit card statements from Celerity Educational Group and noticed a number of inordinate expenses for $1,000 meals at restaurants, spas, those kinds of things.
And so we ask,
What's that all about?
So we received documentation from the, at that time, CEO of Solarity Educational Group, that these were from the other affiliated organizations, Solarity Global, Solarity Development, and other affiliated organizations.
So there was one account, one credit card, that was being passed around to several organizations as we uncovered.
And just to add to that, Devorah Navarro-Reed from the Office of the General Counsel for Los Angeles Unified School District.
There are certain instances that, through oversight, the district has discovered, and just as examples, one was a transfer to global in 2012.
for $2.3 million from two CEG accounts.
And also there was a 2011 loan from CEG to Solarity Development, which is another related organization that Solarity Education Group has, for the amount of $2.5 million, and in 2013 for $1.7 million.
So those are just a few other examples to answer board members' questions.
I'm still confused.
Can I just clarify?
Does L.A.
County also oversee a school still or no?
The school was closed in this past June 30th.
Okay, so I think share the confusion that I hear here about the relationship between the CEG and the global, so you're gonna have to help me understand that.
And then I actually have a question for the department, because what I heard the county say is they offered a condition very similar to the one you're asking us to approve.
I'm sorry.
Pardon and L. A. Ours is enforced now.
Okay And so the I guess I need to know from the department's perspective and whatever happened at a CCS.
What gives the you and our advisory
if it wasn't agreed to at the local level, because for me, and we've talked about this a lot of times, I want the charters approved at the local level as much as possible, because you know these schools, you have relationships with them, and so it's troubling then to have them offer a condition like that at the local level, and it sounds like Solarity didn't take it, but now they come up here and they say, yeah, they will do it, so I'm uneasy about this.
So are you asking Cindy to come up and address that?
Okay.
And the others to sit back down.
They can do whatever they want.
I think they're not sure who's.
I think it's good Ellie's here because this is kind of our understanding when we have conditional
conditions that we recommend and that this board takes them.
They're kind of part and parcel with the whole approval.
So the school's approved and they have to take the condition.
If we find out on the road that they're not meeting it, we would seek revocation because it would be a violation.
On some local approvals, the condition has to be met before the charter school's even considered to be active.
So it's a condition of approval in a different way.
I don't know if that was the case, but we look at ours a little differently.
The conditions kind of just goes with the approval.
So it is, it's kind of a gamble.
I mean, these schools haven't opened.
When you approve these conditions, we're all like, we're hoping that everything works out.
But really, they haven't opened yet.
So we kind of, the oversight kicks in, and we have to do our hardest to ensure that they're following everything that this board approves, following the law, et cetera.
Board Member Williams.
It is sometimes also the case that, and I'm not saying that's the case here, but I've seen other cases before the board where a charter school at the local level
felt like a condition being asked of them was going too far or it hadn't been asked before, but it typically is the case that when they get to the state board, if they're at this level and it's the last level they could go to, then they make the adjustment and make the board decision that they will comply with the conditions we ask, or they wouldn't have done that.
And they knew, Celerity knows coming,
before they came to the ACCS that this was going to be, they saw CDE's recommendation and they knew that this would be a condition that they would need to comply, that they would need to be fully transparent, that they'd need to allow an investigation, an inquiry by CDE anytime CDE asked at every level of the organization.
But I think that Cindy had done, I felt like Cindy had done a good job of explaining the different levels and different relationships.
Maybe we needed a visual schematic to be looking at and that would have been helpful.
But I also know, I think that the Solarity's council or rep is here and also would be eager to address the kinds of questions that have been raised about the finances.
Yeah, I'm wondering when we should go to public comment here.
I can wait.
Okay.
I can't wait.
You cannot wait, okay.
I'm an impatient guy, you know that.
I do want to point out a few things that are on the table here.
First of all, the multi-tiered governance structure that Solarity has is within the law, and it is not an illegal structure to begin with.
However, I am very concerned about the lack of transparency.
I'm very concerned that public funds may be
not as clearly revealed to the authorizer and to the county and to everyone as they should be.
But I do want us to be careful about assuming when we talk about millions of dollars and all that there has been any sort of illegal practice going on.
I can't judge that here today.
We don't have that kind of level of information.
I do believe that the CDE recommendation does
give us a transparent view, will give us a transparent view of the financial situation.
And that is what the county also asked for.
I don't know why Solarity did not agree to that condition at the time.
I certainly wish they had.
But at the same time, it is the same sort of requirement that we would be asking should we go ahead and approve the school.
So I just wanted to
I don't know.
I don't know how to get that out.
And I hear public comment from their board member son.
Do you want to go now?
I'm troubled also by the lack of
would maybe after a public hearing like to hear a little bit more about this bank account thing.
I guess I'm more old-fashioned when it comes to charter schools.
And me, a school, and you have your account, it's clear, there's not these multiple layers, funds are not commingled, all of that.
So I would really want for us, if this were approved, to really look carefully into that and
have a high level of transparency on how all of this operates and how the funding works.
Okay, so now we'll have the public comment.
You'll call them in order, and I just want to say for the audience that the board members are going to get their lunches outside and bring them back so there may be people moving in and out, and that's why.
All right, will the following individuals please line up?
Nathan Arias, Gabriel Builna, Wilbert Estrada, Greta Proctor, Eric Primark.
Go ahead.
Yeah, one minute.
Good afternoon, board members.
My name is Nathan Arias.
I'm the Chief Executive Officer of Soledad Enrichment Action.
We operate one charter school for at-risk youth, and we have 14 satellite locations.
Many are in the same communities, right, that Celerity provides services.
These communities are, you know, they're blighted, they're full of violence, and if there's something, right, that Celerity offers, right, it's hope.
And our communities need hope.
They offer a safe place for these young men and women to dream and receive a quality education.
It offers options and access to a lot of services that they're not getting.
So we urge your support for the celerity schools.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Dr. Gabriel Buelna, Executive Director of Plaza Community Services.
We offer child care in East Los Angeles, downtown Boyle Heights, and other parts of Los Angeles.
I'm also a board member of Solarity Global and a parent
at Solarity Troika.
I wanted to, as a parent, my daughter graduated from Solarity Troika.
It's an excellent school with excellent, with quality teachers, field trips, use of technology, dance, and I was proud as a parent
to be part of the Solarity family.
And as a board member of Global, happy that parent involvement was important and is significant at Solarity.
I'm a little disheartened here that with the representatives from Los Angeles, from LAUSD,
from Alaco to spend so much effort on not allowing these schools to move forward, knowing that Solarity is okay with the conditions, and I would urge you to support Solarity.
Thank you.
Good morning, state board members.
I am Wilbur Estrada.
When I was in sixth grade, I wanted to become a bus driver, a taxi driver, or a pizza deliverer because they were the only ones with lots of loose change and lots of dollar bills.
The world in which I lived was so small that expectations of becoming successful were those of my neighbors who lived in the same building.
In 2005, CEG recruited me as their first teacher, and today I am the principal of one of their California distinguished schools.
I see myself in the face
of all my students that remember my childhood aspirations.
Because of Celerity, I can provide them a premier education.
Through our United Nations Millennium Development Goals curriculum, every student takes part in making a difference, at the same time that it provides their parents an opportunity to be partners in the creation of solutions to change our world.
In one word, CEG helps develop future leaders in at-risk communities such as where I grew up.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Greta Proctor.
I'm an attorney at Procopio, and we represent Solarity Educational Group.
I'm here to answer questions, but I wanted to address a couple things that have been said.
The condition that's proposed by CDE is reasonable, and Solarity agrees to it.
The condition was not previously proposed by LAUSD.
In fact, at the recent denials of two LAUSD renewals for Solarity schools, Solarity came up and offered the condition and was told that
CSD didn't want to work with Solarity.
At LACO, LACO imposed a host of conditions sort of post facto at the board meeting that included the condition that Solarity apply with all future conditions that LACO staff might come up with.
So the condition that they put up on the screen today is only one of like seven or eight conditions that LACO proposed, and Solarity eventually had to walk away because one of them was, and anything else we might impose in the future down the road.
So I wanted to clear up those misconceptions.
I have a lot more to say if you have questions.
And again, I urge you to support some of these schools, which are the best schools in Los Angeles.
Thank you.
Jesse Eggler for the California Teachers Association.
CTA opposes the petition and believes the state board should defer in general to the judgment of the local district and the county office, and as a matter of good government, especially local control.
Thank you.
Eric Premack, Charter Schools Development Center, here representing our general membership and not here necessarily on behalf of any particular school.
We're kind of concerned about some of the precedential issues here, particularly this concept that you can, through the chartering process, insist on peaking inside the books of contractors.
If Solarity is okay with it in this instance, we don't have a problem with it, but this notion that authorizers have a right to do that in every case,
is one that's kind of troubling to us.
The other thing I wanted to say, and this is specifically speaking to Ms.
Burr's comment, I think we've all hoped that this would work at the local level.
I invite you to go look at the recording of the LA Unified District's Committee of the Whole meeting recently where they discussed the chartering process.
I think it's safe to say that it's kind of melting down and collapsing down there.
It's become kind of a bureaucratic nightmare, despite the efforts of many fine individuals down there.
They have 40 pages, single-spaced, of district-required language.
It goes into the charter, all kinds of bureaucracy, and now politics really creeping into the process, and it has collapsed.
And I think we've got a real policy issue we need to grapple with.
Thank you.
Michelle Lowe on behalf of the California Charter Schools Association.
We've been working closely with Solarity not only on their current schools, but on these petitions as well.
These governance structures are common and they are legal.
They're used throughout the charter school sector, and I really would ask you to focus on the academic performance of these schools so far.
They have a proven past performance.
They're performing at or above similar schools with the similar populations.
We would ask you today to follow the recommendation of CDE and the ACCS and approve them.
Thank you.
Okay, I guess now we're ready for further board discussion.
So may I?
Yeah, thank you.
I call on our liaison first because he's charter school liaison.
Thanks.
And I heard a question, I think, from Member Burr asking about what went on at ACCS.
I'm sorry if I got the wrong person.
We heard very similar presentations from both the petitioners and the county and the district at the ACCS meeting.
The same issues that you've been talking about that were presented, the ACCS also dealt with.
In the end, there was, I believe, my summary of it was that there's always concern about transparency, there's always concern about
difficult to understand a governance structure that is more complex than what Ting, you talked about in one school, one account.
That's the way I ran my charter school as well.
But at the same time, ultimately, the ACCS decided that with this condition, they felt satisfied that
there would be proper oversight from the CDE.
And yet the ACCS also spent quite a bit of time looking at the performance of the existing schools.
I asked the CDE to go
into some depth, and I've got all the reports from the CDE about the performance of the celerity schools, and it is pretty impressive, it really is.
English language learners achieving much higher than schools they might attend, overachieving the state average, on and on and on.
There have been a couple of areas in performance that do concern me about the celerity schools, and one of those is suspensions.
There's no expulsions from the celerity schools on record, but the
there are a couple of celerity schools that did have higher suspension rates than the local district.
Other celerity schools had much lower suspension rates than the district.
But at the same time, I really would hope that the celerity schools that have an increased suspension rate, that they would do something about it quickly and work on that issue.
But in
It seems like in every other respect, English language arts, English learners, math, that all the Solarity schools are doing well, if not very well.
And once again, 98% free and reduced lunch, or 100% free and reduced lunch, 98% Latino or African American.
These are very,
These are kids that need opportunities and Solarity does seem to be giving those sorts of opportunities.
So I just wanted to go through what I had researched and give you the ACCS view.
All right, so I waited on my comment for the public comment because I do have some questions and I am confused.
I heard the conversation, the explanation about the governance structure.
I am not confused that the type of government structure proposed and that currently exists
I'm not confused by the idea that it's allowed under the law.
That does not confuse me.
What confuses me is the operation of this governance structure that does not appear to be within the intent or the spirit of the law that allows this governance structure to exist.
And so one of the reasons why I was confused, and I frankly was not confused about it until everybody started talking about it today,
was this letter that was given and the level of investigation that was done both by the district and the county office concerning the interaction and the operation of the two entities that form this governance structure.
So if I'm under, and this is where I believe I'm about to make a misstatement, so I'm going to ask the LAUSD to correct me on this.
If I'm understanding correctly, there was a condition given similar to the condition that's being proposed by the department about the interaction that the district would have on the oversight.
Solarity said that they could not accept that condition because this other part of their governance structure would be bound to that condition, and they could not do that.
But at the same time, today we're hearing that they are a vendor.
So I need to understand, for this other group, global, are they a part of the governance structure or are they a vendor?
And was there a condition actually given either by the county office or LAUSD that was similar to what our department is proposing today
that Solarity turned down because they're saying they didn't turn it down because it was never offered, but there's a letter saying they did.
So now I'm lost.
So let me unpack the question.
First of all, what is global in relationship to Solarity?
Are they a part of the governance structure or are they a vendor?
First, let me answer the question about the condition.
No, I'd like you to answer that one first.
That one, I'll ask legal counsel.
Good morning, board member.
It is through our oversight and through our questioning of this very governance structure that we have discovered that Solarity Global seems to be a part of the governance structure of the Solarity Education Group charter schools.
by the mere fact that they are sole statutory members with the right, as explained by Ms.
Chan, to merge the corporation, appoint and select board members, remove board members, and also dissolve the corporation.
And they select the board members for celerity, is that correct?
For CEG.
They have the right to.
Okay, that's a different answer than, are they selecting the board members for CEG?
And that is a question that we have posed previously to the authorizer, to CEG, and only as far as basically October 25th after we had our two non-renewals did they provide an answer, not necessarily an answer, but basically a list
of Celerity Global board members that we have been asking for.
So they have not actually answered that question.
That's probably a question that's better suited.
Okay.
And I'm not getting the answer here.
I don't mean to be short with you, but this is a really important point.
And I see the people from Celerity who want to jump on that question, so I'd like to give them an opportunity to answer that for me.
Is this group global a vendor for you, or are they a part of your governance structure?
So would somebody from Solarity like to come and explain that to me?
Yes.
That's part of the governance structure.
Yes, so my name is Greta Proctor, again, attorney for Solarity Educational Group from the Procopio Law Firm, and Solarity Global Development is the sole statutory member of CEG.
That was a structure that was put into place in 2012 when Global was created as a non-profit entity to support Solarity.
Stop.
Okay, I got that.
Okay.
I understand who they are.
My question remains, are they a part of CEG's governance structure?
That's a yes-no question.
No.
Okay, stop.
Okay.
So now does this group appoint any board members for CEG?
No.
Solarity Educational Group board members are elected by the Solarity Educational Group board members, much like all other charter schools that I know of in California.
The difference here is that under the Corporations Code, whenever you have sole statutory membership, by definition under 5056, that means you have a few rights, and one of those is the right to approve or remove board members.
CEG has never exercised that right, or Global has never exercised that right, I should say, over the CEG board.
Global has never appointed or removed CEG board members.
But they do have that statutory and contractual right.
Yes.
Okay.
And that's built into the corporation's code.
Okay, so then as it relates to the condition that was given to CEG, and again, I'm not clear on who gave the condition, whether it was the county office or the district themselves, there was a condition raised that CEG said they couldn't accept, and it's a printed letter,
that said that they could not accept that condition because it bound global in a way that they were not entitled or they didn't have the authorization to bind global.
If global is only a vendor and not a part of the governance structure, how is it that CEG thinks that they are binding global to that condition?
The condition that LACO proposed, and it was one of many,
was to say CEG will warrant that Global will comply with everything that LECO wants.
And CEG said we can't warrant that on behalf of Global.
Because, because.
They are a separate, sorry, a separate entity from Global.
Now the condition that CDE proposed is so long as CEG wants to continue this governance structure and contract with Global, which again is within the realm of what CEG's board gets to decide whether or not they want to do, then Global and CEG both need to,
acknowledge this increased transparency and CEG has said we're okay with that because we can control that.
Either Global does it or we no longer contract or have this governance structure with Global.
Okay, so you're an attorney and I know that you can answer this question for me.
You know, California is a governing state in Smarter Balanced.
You don't have to have read the contract for California as being a governing state in Smarter Balanced.
But when we signed that contract, one of the elements in that contract was there were conditions we had to agree to as part of that consortium.
Am I understanding you to say that Global, as a part of the governing structure with CEG, in signing the contract or the agreement they have with CEG, can pick and choose which conditions or requirements that CEG has with their authorizer that they will or will not accept?
No, not at all.
So why did CEG say they couldn't make the agreement to that condition?
That's the part I'm not getting then.
CEG denied that set of conditions primarily for the last condition.
I'm only talking about this one thing because that's what the letter said.
Okay, so for this particular condition, it was because the condition was, you, CEG, will warrant that Global will do A, B, and C. And CEG said, we can't warrant that Global will do A, B, and C. We can only warrant that we continue a relationship with Global and a contract with Global or not.
So did CEG ever present that condition?
And this is getting to a level of extraction I apologize for, but I am trying to be clear on whether or not the relationship that CEG had with global
is a point of interference on what happened with this charter.
So did CEG ever talk, in your understanding, ever talk to Global about this condition and how it would have an impact on their contractual relationship?
I was part of a meeting between LACO staff and CEG staff, where we sat in a room and we said... That's not what I'm asking.
I'm asking, to your knowledge, did CEG and Global have a conversation about their contractual relationship with LACO?
What contractual relationship with LACO?
That's my point.
That's because CEG was making the condition that LACO was establishing and about the contract between CEG and Global, they were creating something that was tangentially related to that contract.
I'm asking, did CEG and Global have a conversation about that issue?
I don't know.
Okay.
I don't understand that one.
Okay, so, all right, thank you.
I don't mean to be dismissive, I just don't want you to think I'm being, I just want to make sure because my colleagues are going, I waited, I just want to make sure you know I waited.
So my next question is about the funding and about the, was there something else?
Go ahead.
I mean, it's the county office that offered that condition, and it says if CEG is going to continue to contract with vendor, then just similar to what the condition before the board here is today.
And because of what the bylaws, CEG bylaws state is that the decisions of CEG board are subject to approval by global.
Yeah, I'm real clear.
I read that.
I got that.
Yeah, so whereas global has powers over CEG, CEG has no power over global, so they would have to agree.
In fact, I think global would have to agree to the condition that's being presented as well.
CEG, as Ms.
Proctor said, can't agree for global.
I agree with everything you just said.
I read that.
I have better than a third grade level of reading comprehension.
But even my third graders would have read the same thing and understood that.
So I get that.
But what I'm confused by is there seems to be a different interpretation about what that sentence in the agreement means among the two parties who have this agreement.
What I'm not understanding and what I'm confused by
I don't want anybody to tell me it's allowed under the law.
I get it's allowed under the law, but there seems to be a difference in how the LAUSD and LACO have interpreted the authority that this entity Global has over CEG, and what CEG says is actually how they operate.
What I'm real clear about is, and I do also agree that some of this agreement and some of this information was not presented in their governance structure in what was submitted in the charter.
And so this goes back to the conversation, it's a continuing running conversation that
my colleagues on the board have about what's a technical amendment and what's a material amendment concerning this.
And so the fact that this is going to get clarified in some way as part of the 11 technical amendments that are being made, since that wasn't present before and it wasn't made clear and it wasn't transparent and it wasn't disclosed, I'm not sure I agree that that was purely a technical amendment, but that's a different issue.
Let me ask about this money and this exchange of funds and the movement of funds.
Okay, you named two different lump sums of checks that were written.
I got confused on three things.
Who authorized the payment?
Was that a payment?
Normally, you know, when I was in a school district and all of these contractor payments were authorized,
They were usually approved at a public board meeting, and there was some cost center that it was identified to.
And there were these checks and balances about what it was paid for and distributed.
So I'm not clear in the documents I received how this was authorized, what cost center or program this was authorized for, and how this was checked down or monitored or followed.
So can you give me some clarification on that?
Who are you asking?
Solarity?
No, the county.
The county.
No, you're asking LA County?
I'm asking, yeah.
Not Solarity.
Yeah.
I don't understand why both can't answer that.
Okay, I can ask both of them, but it was raised by her.
I'm asking them because it was raised by them.
That's the primary reason why I'm asking, but both of them can speak to it, but that's the reason why I'm asking them because they're the ones who raised it.
I share that.
At LA County, we do a monthly analysis of all of our charter schools.
We ask them to submit different documents to us.
And when we looked at the period of time of the checks, we were looking at the checks.
The checks, they have a process where two people sign off.
Ms.
Kennedy, I'm hoping I'm saying your name correct.
At the particular time that we looked at the check structure, we were like, why is CEG Global signing off on checks when she resigned?
So we went and started counting the checks.
And when we look back at the checks, there's a total of 47 checks between July, August, and September of 2015, where the CEO of Global signed off on checks, single signatures,
$1.8 million, and of those 47 checks, 10 of those checks mounting to 1.2 were written to Global or any of these other, Solarity Contracting, Attenture, Solarity Development, and that's when we started looking to see whenwe went back and said, well, when does she leave?
And when we went back and looked, she left April 2015, but she still had authority to sign the checks.
There was also a transfer of assets that took place in 2012, and CEG Board had approved that transfer of assets.
And I think it's important to note at that time, the current CEG Board was also on the Board of Global and participated in that.
discussion and vote as well.
So there were a couple of times when it was transferred.
One of the reasons that we did not know about this is that these weren't in CEG's audits.
This transfer was in Global's audits.
We were given, I think,
one of Global's audits when we requested.
So when we originally found out in 2014 that Global was now the entity that was conducting the management services, in our MOU it says if you change management organizations, it requires a material revision.
So those were the discussions.
Who is now the management company?
Global CEG had grown to now they had
a parent had occurred above global, above CEG, that's now global.
And so they were really doing the management.
In fact, all of the employees at that point worked for global.
All the employees of the charter?
All the employees at the CMO level were working for global.
And they were on global's payroll.
A few have come down now, but there are still a few, like the chief financial officer is actually an employee of global.
So some things changed after that.
But during that process, we started to ask about, well,
If the money is going to global, can we have documentation of how that money is being spent?
It's generated for our students.
Then we think that we should know how the money was being spent.
And we were basically told, no, we don't have access.
You can't have access to those documents.
And I believe LAUSD has experienced the same thing.
Okay, so I'm going to say thank you for the answer you provided, but that was not the question I asked.
And my president wants me to make sure that I ask Solarity the same question so that they have an opportunity to respond.
So let me repeat my question.
The question I asked is, what was the purpose of the expenditure?
How was it approved?
By which board was it approved?
So maybe if I restate the question,
in a way to be clear that I'm trying to understand the paper trail and the approval of the expenditure.
That might be helpful.
So what LACOE and LAUSD did was explain to me that the checks were authorized and signed by someone who had already resigned, and these checks happened after the resignation.
That was not the question I asked.
I wanted to know what the checks were for.
Were they associated with a particular educational program or a particular vending contract?
who approved them and how was that approval done because that's not been made clear.
And so I understand what the two LEAs wanted to do and get on the record, but that was not what my question was about.
So the actual checks that were written were vendor checks for invoices for services, and all of those checks go to our board meetings we meet every other month, and the board approves the financials and the fiscals.
I believe that's your question.
That's my question.
Okay.
And I couldn't find it.
I'm sorry?
I couldn't find the board meeting where those things were approved.
The financials are presented at every board meeting.
Okay, I'll say it again.
I could not find it.
Okay.
So could you tell me what, and so asking you now to tell me what board meeting that was approved for.
Yeah, I don't mean to put you on the spot, but I'm telling you, I could not find it.
Okay.
So I looked.
I'll be happy to.
How would you have found it?
That's my point.
I couldn't figure out where I'm supposed to look.
I couldn't figure out who approved it.
I couldn't figure out which board approved it.
All I saw were the checks.
And so the two LEAs come to talk about who signed the checks, but that's not the issue I have because there is a commingling of funds.
I wanted to understand where all this happened and how it happened, and I couldn't figure it out.
Okay, so I'm not, yeah, so I understand.
Thank you for answering my question, because you actually did answer the question, and I appreciate that.
Thank you.
All right, thank you.
Okay.
Other comments?
Board member comments?
No other?
Board member Ortiz-Lacombe, and then board member, you go first, and then board member Allen.
I want to come back to the recommendation and have a question about it.
Do you have the flexibility within your current system to adhere by the recommendation of the CDE?
Celerity.
Yes, the CEG board has agreed to abide by the CDE's recommendation, and the recommendation is if we're gonna continue contracting with Global, then Global has to answer inquiries and provide documents.
Our board has definitely said yes to that, and we can and will abide to that.
And a follow-up would be,
Does the recommendation also include a clear understanding of how the money is being directed from the schools?
It sounds like you have this general budget where people have call centers and then they identify, we have the same custodial services.
this portion of my money goes into this pod so that we could then execute the check and send it out to the vendor.
Is that a requirement that we're now also, is that part of the recommendation that there is clear understanding of how the money from each school is going out to pay for the vendors versus having a perception of commingling funds?
The recommendation is broad enough for if we find there's reason.
that we want to make an inquiry about any financial transaction that this condition would allow us to do so.
And what if they don't provide the information?
We can revoke them.
We would consider it a condition of approval, and we could issue a notice of violation if the charter school doesn't comply.
And that can be done any time during the length of the charter?
Yes.
As we did with some others.
And you're prepared to follow this and do that?
Yes, okay.
Board member holiday.
Well, I certainly hope that C D. E has a great deal more cooperation in their oversight of this of this charter school should be approved.
Then L A is.
LAUSD or the county seem to have had.
I hope that the sorority schools understand clearly how frustrating and complex a system they've put together that does not necessarily serve them as well as they might have intended, certainly in this particular room today.
Once again, I come back to the notion that
school district.
Um these are Children in this neighborhood that deserve some options and obviously are interested in having these schools in.
I believe five or six of the celebrity schools.
Um in the last year, there's been, uh, increase in
the school closing was a facility issue, not a parental walking with their feet issue, you know, kind of thing.
So I would trust in our department, in our capable hands of Cindy and the financial people in the CDE to monitor the situation carefully, and therefore I would approve the CDE recommendation.
Move, I'm sorry.
Move the approval, is there?
Yes.
Second.
Okay.
I have a comment.
Yes, go ahead.
So when I look at the couple statements I want to make, on the governance structure and on the fiscal issues,
I'll speak for myself, but I think I speak for the board as well, that we take the use, appropriate use of taxpayer dollars in education very seriously, whether you're a traditional district or whether you're a charter school.
I think that the transparency, our ability to know whether or not things are being handled appropriately, fiscally, is very important.
And I would say that not because of celerity, but just in general, those issues have been raised more in the public, both with traditional districts as well as with charter schools, and everybody's pretty, has a heightened awareness of it now.
And certainly I do, as a charter liaison,
So when the governance structures are complex, they can allow for conflicts of interest.
None has been found here.
The ACCS did not find any.
There has been no formal findings issued that there has been that kind of thing.
So I want to make sure that's on the table, because there's been a lot of questions about that.
that wasn't in any of the findings, but it does present the possibility of a conflict of interest.
And so it's in the state board's interest, should we approve celerity that we make sure that we have access to all the financial records and know what's going on with the governance, and that any charter that comes before us, whether it's celerity or some other charter, needs to know that we take the governance structure, as long as they're legal,
But we need to understand them and we need to understand how the money is being spent.
And if we feel in any way like you're not cooperating with the CDE staff or we find anything that is wrongdoing, we'll take appropriate steps to deal with it.
So we're serious about this and want you to know we're serious about it.
So that said, there have been no findings.
It is a legal structure.
They are aware that it has a potential and people are concerned about it, Solarity is.
I think that they will make sure that, I believe that they will make sure that
They are providing us all the access we need.
The ACCS felt like, agreed, felt like the condition that CDE and state board staff developed to make sure that we have that kind of access and ability to investigate is adequate for us to take.
It gives us what we need and doesn't overreach where we shouldn't be overreaching with the charter school.
And in addition, and finally, the law still says that academic, now this is with renewals, but it says academic performance, academic attainment by students should be a top consideration.
And I'm impressed by the academic data that staff presented to Member Holiday and I and before the ACCS that shows that the students in celerity schools
look to be staying.
They look to be growing.
The number of students are growing.
That they are outperforming the district and outperforming the state on averages on English language arts and math.
The EL students are doing terrific.
It looks like a really strong academic and enriched environment.
I love the dance and the performance and the singing, so it's not just sitting down at your desk and doing that kind of work.
That's why Member Holiday and I, those reasons are the reasons why Member Holiday and I are encouraging the board to approve these two celerity schools.
The first one.
Sorry, I can't speak to the second one.
I'm sorry.
I want to follow up on that, and then I'll so I want to ask Cindy Chan to come up.
I'm not sure what this finding would be about.
Board member Williams used to know finding.
But I want to ask you, do you have in your review of this?
Is there evidence that Solarity held back information from the authorizers?
Or was this all just confusion?
I mean, so it seemed like they asked for documents and couldn't get them.
Now, maybe that's all they asked for the wrong thing or all misunderstanding, but there's just a lot of suggestion here that things were asked for and they were not given.
So, I mean, all we had to go by was what was in the record.
I think you heard more verbal testimony here, but I think there's two sides of it.
What we would have looked for, I mean, we had a no in this criteria.
It wasn't a yes, it wasn't a technical amendment, because we feel that this potential warrants the condition, so that's why we had the no, but there wasn't,
evidence, like you had mentioned.
There isn't an audit report.
There's not some sort of a fraud review.
There's nothing that we could bring you that is evidence of really wrongdoing.
I mean, we have the greatest respect for the district and the county, but for us to bring you something to deny the charter, we needed something a little bit more.
and it was just a lot of back and forth.
I mean, some of it is unusual and it's complicated.
I hope it's easier for us if you approve a charter in oversight, but I think in fairness to the charter school, without some sort of an external independent review, it would have been something we would have needed in order for us to kind of take that step further and actually issue a recommendation of a denial for that one criteria.
Board Member Ortiz-Lacon.
I want to thank both Board Member Holliday and Williams for really expressing their firm, not only support, but also affirming that the Board will be very diligent about some of the issues and some of the conditions that have been provided and outlined.
Going back to Board Member Holliday's comment about where these schools are located,
I think that's why I have higher scrutiny, because they are located in communities that are vulnerable communities that have experienced neglect at so many levels.
And because of that, we owe these students the good quality educational opportunities, but also the responsibility of making sure that if they are offered that ray of hope,
that they are also offered a system that will provide stability.
And what I have seen in the past, unfortunately, is with some of these issues, you have great schools with great outcomes, and then the structure, the commingling,
does away with that school or that system or that CMO.
And I don't want to see that for those students because they have already been neglected so much by so many different institutions, structures, and what have you, that I would hate for us to provide that ray of hope.
and then not have the structure in place to sustain it.
So I do look forward to hearing how the schools, if approved, are doing, and hopefully they will be able to keep their doors open for those students that I have trusted in you.
Thank you.
Okay.
Super do you know?
Okay Um.
No other comments.
All right, so we've had the motion and we're ready for a vote.
All those in favor of the motion.
Raise your hands.
So those opposed.
One opposed.
Okay.
You know what?
Anybody abstained?
No.
Okay, so the motion is carried, and now we're ready for the second public hearing, which is another
Item 19.
Item 19 is an appeal.
Again, this is Cindy Chan, Charter Schools Division, California Department of Education.
Item 19 is an appeal by Celerity Rolos Charter School to establish a new school, new charter school, denied by the Los Angeles Unified School District and the Los Angeles County Board of Education.
The CD received the appeal from Solarity Roll-Us on August 1st, and based on a review of the petition documents and information submitted, which is pretty much identical to the prior petition that you deliberated on, the CD is recommending the State Board hold a public hearing and thereafter approve with two conditions and 11 technical amendments the request to establish
celerity roll-offs under the oversight of the State Board for a five-year term, effective July 1, 2016, through June 30, 2021.
As part of the approval, our recommendation is for these following two conditions, which are the same as the ones in the previous item.
Number one, Solarity Educational Group may only continue to contract with Solarity Global Development for goods and or services if Solarity Educational Group and Solarity Global Development agree to timely respond to all of the California Department of Education inquiries into Solarity Educational Groups and Solarity Global Development's operations, including but not limited to management fiscal personnel, procurement facilities operations, facilities financing,
and programmatic services in accordance with Education Code section 47604.3, and fully cooperate with any investigation into their operations conducted pursuant to Education Code section 47604.4.
Condition two is that Solarity rule last must adhere to the terms and conditions as noted in attachment one of the item, State Board of Education standard conditions on opening and operation.
So the Advisory Commission on Charter Schools considered this petition at its October 4th meeting and voted to recommend that the State Board approve the petition with the conditions and technical amendments as proposed by the CDE.
The motion passed with a vote of five to one.
Celerity Rolos is proposing to serve approximately 390 pupils in transitional kindergarten through grade five in year one, expanding to 565 pupils in TK through grade eight by year five.
Solarity Roll-Us proposes to offer a site-based matriculation setting with a commitment to increasing achievement of at-risk pupils from communities in need within LAUSD.
So since the petition and the documents, aside from the location, are identical, I was going to, I can either represent or I can represent parts or pieces or all of it.
If you'd like, I was gonna try to just briefly summarize our recommendation, and then I can always come back for any questions or anything you wanna ask.
So to summarize, we find that the celerity rule loss petition
With the CD's recommended TAs adequately describes the educational program, provides an adequate description of the multiple required elements, and that the financial plan appears to be reasonably sufficient to support the intended program.
However, we find that the petition presents a governance structure which may compromise the petitioner's ability to successfully implement the intended program, and as a result,
we have recommended a condition to address this concern.
So again, the representatives from the charter school and the district and county are here if you have any questions.
Okay, so any board comments at this point, technical questions?
I know that we've talked this, Jeanette.
I actually do have a question I am curious about.
In setting up the governance structure and the structure that currently exists,
to what extent does this type of structure support the organization in supporting students?
So why would you set up a structure in this way, causing some of this confusion and lack of transit in order to serve students?
Because I know charter schools are organizational innovations.
And so what about this that actually serves kids better?
Again, my name is Greta.
I'm an attorney for Solarity.
In 2012, the idea was to create a support arm for Solarity Educational Group.
And one of the other entities that's been referred to here is the LLC.
You know, that's a single member property holding LLC that supports
charter schools, the Solarity charter schools in the facility arena.
And Solarity Global Development supports the charter schools in all kinds of other arenas, like having a very robust professional development arm, incorporation of the United Nations Millennial Development Goals into the Solarity curriculum, protection and licensing of the Solarity curriculum,
enhancement of the solarity curriculum at a high level that then trickles down to the charter schools.
So that was the intent and some of that has subsequently been pulled back internally into CEG and some of that is still being done at the global level.
Okay, so we have a public hearing to run, so we'll do it in the same order we did last time.
The proponents who want to speak on behalf of supporting this CDE recommendation that the board approve the charter school have 10 minutes.
I declare the public hearing open.
Last one I got was such a small print.
I totally thought I'd give it to you.
So I took out all the direct change.
Good afternoon.
My name is Achilla Gillis, and I'm the director of expanded learning for Celerity Educational Group.
So the Ernie Roloff's population will mirror those of the surrounding schools.
On average, 81% of the community students qualify for the free or reduced lunch program, and 28% of the students are English learners.
The community is mostly Latino and African-American students.
The principal is the instructional leader of the charter school and is responsible for shaping the instructional program, establishing a positive school culture, and helping students to achieve.
One of our strengths is our ability to tailor our educational programs to fit the needs of individual students by creating and implementing individual learning plans.
We have high expectations for all students, and we are committed to working with students who are not meeting outcomes to help them achieve at expected levels.
All special education teachers will hold an education specialist instruction credential and EL certifications, while our counselors and psychologists will have pupil personnel services credentials.
Our expanded learning program provides all of our students the ability to extend the school day to before school, after school, and during the summer months.
Technology is a huge part of the instructional program that makes it stand out.
Our students use laptop computers from the first day of transitional kinder through eighth grade.
Students interact with our different programs on the computers to prepare for the Smarter Balanced exam and to bridge the technology gap that is one of the key divides of the 21st century.
Finally, through our robust performing arts department, we nurture the whole child.
All students take part in dance, vocal, and acting instruction that are aligned to the California visual and performing arts standards.
They produce three performances per year in which they not only learn about the dances, but they learn of cultures from different parts of the world.
And now a short video from parents, students, and teacher perspectives.
My name is Kenyon Johnson and I graduated Solarity in 2008.
My name is Sarah.
I have two boys, second grade and seventh grade.
So my name is Katie and I'm a first grade teacher here.
Why it was important for my family to come to Solarity because I was going to school at Willowbrook Middle School in Compton and I was getting fights almost every day.
When I was searching for a new school for my child coming out of preschool, my big concern was classroom size, school size overall, and of course, scores, test scores, how they do overall with everything, and diversity.
I was looking for a school that had a little bit of everything, and that's what I found here at Solarity.
I didn't get into no more fights.
It was a more peaceful environment.
The teachers were more one-on-one with your education.
You got the attention that you needed as well as the help that you needed to succeed in classes.
Some of the special activities throughout the school, like the dance programs, the dance shows, those are always really fun and exciting, especially for my older son.
He likes to try out for the student parts, and then you get to be the star, and then it builds their confidence, their speaking voice.
My older son was in speech therapy, and he got one of the lead roles last year, and that really bumped up his confidence.
extremely.
By me being at Solarity a trailblazer as I'm going through life, I'm sort of a trailblazer wherever I go.
Solarity has been good for my career because I think it's really shown me all aspects of learning.
I think we have so many different programs here at Solarity, such as our Dream Project, our Science FOSS kits, and different curriculum for language arts and math and social studies, that has kind of opened up my eyes to all of the different tools that there are for teachers, and Solarity does a great job supporting that.
It's really nice to be able to talk to your teachers every day.
I've never had a problem with communication with my teachers.
If there's a problem, I know about it.
If there's something good, I know about it.
And you can't do that with a school of 1,000.
It's not possible.
When you're from the inner city, we don't get exposed to a lot of positive things.
Once you put your child in a celerity environment, they're going to not only get that one-on-one education, but opportunities will open elsewhere if you're serious with your kid.
If you're considering celerity schools, I would tell them just to think about if you want something that's on the smaller level, as far as just the size, this is the place.
My name is Grace Canada, and I'm the CEO of Celerity Educational Group.
I'm grateful for the opportunity to stand here before you today.
On behalf of the CEG Board of Directors, I accept the condition presented by the CDE staff and humbly request that you accept the staff report and recommendations for the establishment of Celerity Rolas Charter School.
Thank you.
Okay, that concludes the
Proponents side and now the opponents have 10 minutes.
Once again, I'm Robert Perry, Charter Schools Division, Los Angeles Unified School District.
I just want to bring a point of clarity.
We, in our district, our board does not issue conditions.
And to the board member's question a moment ago, what we have are benchmarks that we expect that our board issues that are
similar to conditions, but the approval or denial is not contingent upon it, they have to come back and report to our board.
And Celerity has to come back in this month and report to the board on this condition, and that is the organization has to consistently respond to reasonable requests by the authorizer in a timely manner.
And so far we have not seen that to be true.
We are hopeful that it will be henceforth.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, board members.
Devorah Navarro-Reed, LAUSD General Counsel's Office.
With the approval of the first celerity item, celerity Hamelia, we are available to answer any more questions that the board may have.
I would just like to state that we do look forward to the sharing of documents from the State Board of Education and from CDE with the conditions that's already been approved from the first item, so that finally, hopefully, and finally, we can have the answer
that board member Rucker was asking us into that we couldn't really articulate to the board's satisfaction because those are the very questions that are still pending.
Those are the very concerns that we still have and
Just wanted to also reiterate that although these are not actual findings as far as misappropriation or misuse, our findings are about the lack of transparency.
So just wanted to stress that, and again, look forward to the sharing of documents from the State Board and from the CDE that Celerity will henceforth be providing you.
Thank you.
Once again, I'm Dina Wilson from Los Angeles County Office of Education.
Just a few items that we do want to point out.
I concur with Ms.
Reed that our office and our board have asked over and over again the purpose of this affiliation, and we were not given a satisfactory answer, and neither was our board.
I just wanted to restate,
Although Miss Canada has said that CEG board is agreeing to this condition that's proposed by the state board today, in a reviewing of their, any board agenda since this has been proposed, it's not an item on a CEG board agenda related to this particular item here today.
So if discussions have been taking place, it's something that has not been done in a public forum.
We've also like to state out that there are some similar findings in the CDE report, and we do not agree that a lot of these are technical amendments.
They're actually material changes to the petition.
Asking for an expanded description or a proper description of the governance structure is way more than technical at this point.
We also would like to point out that there has been a very similar petition with the CMO structure that also has a sole statutory member.
It was recently submitted to the SBE on appeal.
However, because of the material changes made to the governance structure, this organization was told that the SBE would not hear this appeal and they were advised to either seek judicial review or
as they have rewritten their petition to make these material changes, re-petition to the local board.
I did want to find out or just point out real quickly, we did talk a little bit about data and we talked about data at the ACCS as well.
We do see that they have increased overall for a majority of their schools school-wide in both English language arts and math on the SBAC results.
However, for EL students, four of the seven schools actually decreased in English language arts and two of the seven decreased for math.
We see gaps for students with disabilities and also English language learners in both ELA and math.
Member Holiday brought up the suspension rates.
When we analyzed suspension rates, Celerity Sirius was the school that was under our authorization.
From 2012 and 2013, they had higher suspension rates than each of the resident schools within Compton Unified.
In fact, it was three times higher than the next school.
Within that, 80% of the suspensions were for African American students who make up only 44% of the population that year.
Within LAUSD, all but two of the six schools had a higher suspension rate than the district as a whole.
We also reviewed enrollment data, and in 2015-16, we see that all but one of the schools was under-enrolled.
The data shows that last year, they were under enrollment projections anywhere from 31 to 164 students.
We've also seen attrition from year to year.
A cohort in 2013, by the time those students had reached three years later in 2015-16, there was approximately 71% decrease in that cohort of students.
We don't present this data to necessarily say that all these schools are bad, but to show that there are definitely areas of improvement needed at their current schools, both for student programs, but also definitely in operation and governance, and that they should focus on these schools perhaps rather than replicating and expanding at this moment.
April Mitchell will share some more of our financial data.
I think the only thing, the other items that I would like to express is that we did, at LACO, we did ask for global audits from 13 to current, and we did not receive them, but we did get the 13.
And there is evidence of co-mingling funds.
And from 2013 to the time that we stopped our review, $9.6 million left CEG and went to global, and we were unable to
We don't know where the funds actually went once they went to the affiliation in 2013.
2.3 was cash, and it actually put a cash flow deficit on the schools, and they had to go out and borrow $5.7 million in the next years to just have cash, because they had given so much money away in the transfer of assets and loaning money for purchasing of properties, which
has not been disclosed in either Global's 2013 audit or in any of CEG's financial records.
The other thing I just want to touch on is that the CMO fee that is opposed on the schools from Global is about 12% of their total revenues that they receive, and then in 14-15, they oppose an additional
new fee, which they call ADA miscellaneous fee, which increased about 79% from one year to the next on an average between years 2011 to 2014.
The average CMO fee that was charged from global of CEG was about $457,000.
And within the last year of our operations, between 14 and 15, it went up an additional $405.
$1,000 when they added on the additional miscellaneous fee, which we could not, through the contracts, could not determine why you went from $457,000 to $862,000.
The other thing that when global
When CEG is not operating in a positive with their schools, what they do is they transfer money through a donation.
from Global, and then Global turns around and invoices 12% on total revenue, so they're getting additional funding there, too.
There's a lot of things that we asked for clarification that we could not receive.
We also asked for the audits.
We could not trace the dollars that were transferred back from Solarity Schools to Global.
And it's just an ongoing, looking at what we saw,
The transactions from the loans, the CMO fees, the additional fees, it really put a stress on all of the charter schools, and having to borrow money just to operate.
We're just saying there's an ongoing concern between the relationship with CEG and Global.
And just to summarize, it was mentioned before, but an authorizer's job is twofold, to ensure quality educational programs, but also protecting the public interest.
Both LAUSD and LACO have been unable to do our job as authorizers to ensure that the public interest is being protected due to CEG's lack of transparency and cooperation with the authorizer.
Thank you.
Okay, thank you.
I wanted to start off asking CDE, the Los Angeles Unified and County talk about lack of timely response on these transparency items.
Do you have standards for what is timely?
And if it's not submitted, how do you follow up?
Because it seems like that might be an issue.
I think it depends on what it is.
I mean, because we do ask a lot of information from our schools.
On new charters, we have standard timelines, so when a charter gets approved by the board, we have very specific timelines that we require them to revise their petition, to get their DOJ SANS information.
In this case, I think before they open, we would want this assurance that both of the organizations and the charter school
agree to that condition, so that would be something we would want timely.
But no, we don't have anything really set.
Sometimes it's more urgent.
Typically if it's a financial issue, we want something quicker because we want to make sure that the school don't become insolvent.
So I think it's a case-by-case, but we don't let things linger for a year.
We end up having
multiple communications, the staff checking with their schools on a regular basis.
So it's a constant communication, but things that are more formal, they usually have weeks to maybe a month, and given consideration, if the school has to take something to its board for approval before they submit back, we have to allow that time, but we don't let things, we try not to let anything lag out too long.
Okay well I think that's a concern the board or at least I have is whether these we will get timely responses not just the responses so when is the question so you may think about that over time.
Board member Strauss.
So I just want to first thank LAUSD and LA County for their really thorough analysis
and your really specifics about what your efforts were to monitor in your role as authorizer, and also to share with us the specifics that we have to consider in the authorization.
I do think it's a tension between management practices that we would like to be different, and which we've tried to add conditions, and then what Member Holiday said is the benefit in these communities to have a positive environment with options for kids to give them hope.
that may far exceed what the local neighborhood schools have.
So I think it's too bad, really, that it came to this point.
I just would say to Solarity, I wish you'd responded more timely and given your authorizers the appropriate timely response of the information.
I think I share several board's comments at it.
I prefer this locally authorized and locally supervised.
I don't think it's our intent to authorize everything at the state level, but I just wanna thank LA County and LA Unified because I recognize that you made your sincere efforts and we do have some successful schools with maybe not the best financial oversight and responsiveness.
So I just wanna go back to Cindy and just say, do you believe these assurances and conditions that the department
and I think Nick's been involved in that as well, that you've put in will remediate the problems the local authorizers have had that forced these to come here.
Because we're at such a high level now, it's so much out in the public arena, we're hoping that
This discussion just helps to have the organizations respond to us if we find a need to.
And again, it's if we find a need.
It isn't an automatic.
So as we're doing oversight, if we find something that we need to ask about, we would expect a response in a pretty immediate fashion.
And then the other question, just to clarify, this authorization goes as of July 2016 to 2021, so how does that affect this year when we're in November of 2016 well into the school year?
Is this anticipated that we'll open in the following year and they'll just lose one year of their
charter petition?
Yes, this year will have to be a planning year for the school, and the reason is because those dates were hard-coded into the petition.
We talked about dates at the last meeting.
Sometimes they're in there, sometimes it's more of a letter of intent.
These dates were in there in various places, so we could not have them changed because that would be a fairly material change.
So I think just the timing of how
The petition progressed locally through that process and through the appeal.
Time lagged on to the point where we're here now in the year that they wanted to open.
So what we did was we looked at the budget in sort of a shift, knowing that year one would really be next year, but we could not allow for that change to occur by shifting the term.
The term stays five years, but the operational term for the school only before.
And then this question may not be under the CDE, but the problems that have occurred with celerity have occurred in locally authorized and county authorized schools.
So there are still schools in operation now.
I know a couple have closed.
So did celerity in the process indicate that they would now
remediate their issues with their local authorizer.
Again, it's not related to this particular, but they still have other schools that they have a responsibility to be transparent and address these issues.
So I just wonder.
We have been issued a letter by Dr. Canada, and we are going to make arrangements to sit down and we're hopeful.
What does that mean?
We hope that they'll be transparent with us.
We're going to sit down with them about their other schools, and we hope they'll be transparent with us.
Okay, in this way, do we need to move to public comment or not?
Do we?
Just following up on board member Strauss's comments, I, too, want to thank the district and the county representatives for being here.
We listened very carefully to what you say, and I thought your presentations were excellent.
We agree with a lot of the issues and concerns, not necessarily the final outcome, perhaps.
But I, too, hope that through this process of transparency and clarity with the CDE that it will benefit the local authorizers as well and that the information is shared and that together we can bring everything into the light.
Do you want to wait for public comment or?
I just have one.
Okay.
So my comment was, I don't think this is just complex.
It's actually really messy.
And I hope that we don't have to, at this level, deal with that level of mess.
Because, well, I'm putting the hope out into the universe.
But one of my concerns, the schools will open in the fall of 2017.
The CMO had two schools that were not renewed at the local level.
I anticipate that perhaps they will eventually make their way up here again.
And I want to make sure that at that point we have some experience with their timely response.
Now, you know, I agree with Dr. Kurz, timely is so subjective.
My husband and I have very different interpretations.
as to what is timely, right?
But I do think that we owe it to them to know what timeline and what we mean by timely, and there's gonna be some things that perhaps could be submitted a little later, and they're not as urgent as other things.
But it's good for us to know, well, just some little testing versus financials, or this, or verification.
And so at what point do we say, you know, you missed three of your deadlines that are pretty significant and had a very specific deadline?
Is it three opportunities that we give?
What would give the department
sort of that push to submit a letter stating we've tried to work with you for the last month, or I'm not sure how that protocol, but I think that it's important for there to be a common understanding of what the timeline is and what the first step would be if the first couple of deadlines that are pretty urgent are not met.
Thanks.
The state board schools that you've authorized are very responsive to us.
We've had a couple of schools recently, and they are no longer active.
One of them was very untimely, and so it got to the point where we would issue letters of concern.
They would get, I think, a little more serious in terms of the nature of the message where,
a notice of violation was mentioned.
A notice of violation is the first step of revocation.
So we had a school that wasn't handling the responses and we ended up seeking out revocation of that school.
So I mean, we don't want to get to that with any school, but that is an outcome if a school doesn't respond and we feel like the nature of the inquiry is so serious that it warrants immediate response.
And I don't think we've ever been unreasonable in what we've asked for, but it would be something that, of course, is related to the school itself, the pupils, so the educational program, and, of course, the finances.
So it runs the gamut as to the types of letters we issue, but they do get a little more serious in nature.
The timelines shorten if we don't get responses timely.
So we have done that, and we are,
going to carry that out if that occurs.
Okay, one more and then I'm going to public comment.
Okay, Cindy, this question is for you.
Earlier this year, we approved a charter that days after the board meeting approved that charter, they submitted a material revision to their charter that we had to hear about the following board meeting.
And during that board meeting, it was disclosed that they had an agreement with you that they were going to have to do this.
And so I'm at the reason why I'm raising that is because, as you said, in this charter, there are some hard deadlines that they were supposed to be doing to try to open their school this year.
And so now this is going to be a planning year.
So I need to ask so that we don't have another surprise as I was taken aback by that surprise.
Do you believe as a result of the fact that they will open a year later,
Even though technically the deadline, the timelines that they identified for some of the things concerning opening this year are different, do you believe in your conversations, because they're opening a year later, that they may need to consider some material revisions, and have they been advised about that concerning the difference in opening next year instead of this year?
I don't believe so.
The one thing that this school does not have is a facility, so we've talked about that.
In the next item, we'll talk a little more about what's required of the facility.
In this case, they did provide the size of the facility that they thought they'd need.
I mean, it's Los Angeles, so I think there are options.
There are more options for them than some of the other, I think, petitions we've seen where the communities are a little more residential.
So we weren't as concerned with that.
There is time for that.
That, I think, because they're an existing organization, and they're not just, they've started schools, I don't think we had that hesitation.
The facility would be the only thing at this point, and ensuring that they have the enrollment.
I mean, the signatures are there, but that would be the other piece.
I'm asking because the other thing that was disclosed by these folks, even though they stood here at the hearing and talked about all the work that they were that was already ongoing and the work that they had undertaking, the truth was they weren't doing any of that.
And so that's part of the reason why they want to do the material revision on their grade levels, because they weren't doing any of the things they originally presented as actual truth to the board at the previous meeting.
So that's the reason why I'm asking about that.
Is it likely that they may have to make some of those changes based on the fact that they're going to have to delay?
Not based on the conversations or the information that we've received, so nothing that we know of.
Only thing pending is the facility.
Okay, thank you.
Okay, public comment.
Will the following people please stand up?
Sheila Whitley, Jesse Aguilar, Angela DeRamos, Ken Burt, Raul Marches, Nathan Arias, Gabriel Bueno, Greta Proctor, and Michelle Wu.
This is Jesse Aguilar for the California Teachers Association.
CTA opposes the petition and believes the state board should defer in general to the judgment of the local district and the county as a matter of good government and especially local control.
Thank you.
Hi, my name is Raul Macias.
I'm president and founder of Anagua Youth Sport Association in Los Angeles, in Northeast Los Angeles.
Thank you, board members, for all the jobs you're doing.
And in this time, you have one of the hardest jobs.
Celerity is one of the best institutions in our part of this Los Angeles city.
I have worked with them for almost seven years.
Most of my kids, besides studying, they go to the fields, and I can see the difference.
I can see the difference because I saw my kids more,
mature and disciplined.
And this is the gap between the sport and education.
Our community needs a lot of this work because we have a big problem with the density of the kids.
please give us the support because this is one of the best thing for our community.
Thank you.
and public comment, so we are now ready for public discussion.
Round two.
Once again, I think that we had the right vote on the first Solarity school, and I would hope that that would happen again.
I certainly think that
I fully trust in the department to do high quality oversight of these two schools, both financially and performance based academically.
So I would go ahead and move that we accept the CDE recommendation for approval of this Solarity school.
I would second that.
I would only say, I think there's been a number of board members concerned about the transparency issue, and so I know a celerity is here in his name.
The board will be curious about how this all comes out.
Any other comments from board members?
No?
Okay, all those ready to vote?
All those in favor, raise your hands.
Those opposed?
I'm not opposed.
One abstention.
Okay, thank you.
We're now on to item 20.
petition for the establishment of charter school, Winton Charter High School in Merced County.
Good afternoon, again, Cindy Chan, Director of the Charter Schools Division at the California Department of Education.
Item 20 is an appeal by the Winton Charter High School to establish a new charter school, which was denied by the Merced Union High School District and the Merced County Board of Education.
The CD received the Winton appeal on June 8th, 2016.
Oh, you can't hear me.
Based on a review of the petition documents and information submitted, the CD is recommending that the State Board hold a public hearing and thereafter deny the petition to establish Winton under the oversight of the State Board of Education based on the CD's findings that the petitioner is unlikely to successfully implement the program set forth in the petition and that the petition does not provide a reasonably comprehensive description of the required charter elements.
The Advisory Commission on Charter Schools considered the Winton Petition at its October 4th meeting and voted to recommend that the State Board deny the Winton Charter Petition by a vote of six to zero.
Winton is proposing to serve approximately 200 pupils in grade nine through grade 12 in year one, increasing to 800 pupils by year five in the Winton community.
Winton proposes to provide all pupils with an exceptional education that will allow them to excel inside and outside of the classroom by offering pupils a rigorous core curriculum, outstanding staff, high standards and expectations, extended instructional hours, and personalized learning opportunities.
So again, as part of our review of the charter petition, we determine whether the petition sufficiently meets the required statutory criteria.
That include whether the charter school presents a sound educational program, the petitioners are able to successfully implement that intended program, and the petition contains reasonably comprehensive descriptions of the required elements.
Based on review of the Winton petition documents, we find the petition adequately describes the educational program and addresses how it will serve Winton's target population with the addition of recommended TAs that we're proposing.
However, we find that the remaining two criteria were not sufficiently met and are the basis for findings of fact supporting the grounds for denial.
So the first finding, the petitioner's ability to successfully implement the intended program.
The regulations require a number of factors that we look at and that must be met.
in order for this element to be met.
So this includes the capacity of the petitioner, including any past history the petitioner has with charter schools or education, the sufficiency of the financial and operational plan, and whether the facilities needed are adequately described to operate the size and scope of the educational program, and that the projected costs are reasonable for acquisition or lease.
So I'm gonna start with the first factor,
And I'll start it off with the actual regulation or the legal requirement that's in the regulation.
We find the following to be of great concern which supports the finding.
And the first one is the petitioner has a past history of involvement in charter schools or other education agencies.
The history is one that is regarded as unsuccessful.
So as noted in the Merced Union High School District findings, Dr. Juan Martinez, the Wynton-Lee petitioner, has had his teaching and administrative credentials revoked by the California Commission on Teacher Credentialing.
We confirmed that Dr. Martinez's
standard elementary teaching credential, a designated subjects adult education teaching credential, and a people personnel services credential were revoked for misconduct effective November 4th, 2012.
There was a web link that was provided in the item that would take you to that CTC webpage.
The CD finds this to be of significant concern in determining whether the Winton petitioner is demonstrably likely to successfully implement the program as the CTC found clear and convincing evidence of misconduct.
We believe that this will undermine the Winton petitioner's ability to recruit staff as well as families to the charter school.
The second factor is that the petitioner personally lacks the necessary background in areas critical to the charter school's success, nor does the petitioner have a plan to secure the services of individuals who have the necessary background in curriculum, instruction and assessment, and finance and business management.
So the petition makes reference to key positions, and what we look for is that it outlines key petitions that the charter school intends to employ or to use, and it provides descriptions and qualifications, and that's usually typical of what we look for and what's required in the petition.
In this case, there were a number of positions that were noted in the petition, and I'll mention a few of them, intervention teacher, director of special education, program specialist, an instructional coach, a person responsible that will handle and oversee the independent audit function.
These positions were mentioned, but there was no description of qualifications provided.
Additionally, the petition does not require their teachers to be cross-cultural learning and academic development certified, which we find important given that the petition states that half of the Whitman's pupil population to be served are English learners.
So we find that that factor was not met.
Factor three, related to the financial plan.
The petitioner has presented an unrealistic financial and operational plan for the proposed charter.
As part of the process in reviewing the financial plan, we begin with the petitioner's budget, and then we review it looking for assumptions that are provided, and then we make adjustments to that based on what we feel is conservative or accurate to revenues and expenditures.
After applying our adjustments to the Winton budget, we find that the Winton petitioner has presented an unrealistic financial and operational plan for the proposed charter schools.
It relates to facilities.
So facilities is another factor in this criteria, and I'm gonna read what we are looking for in the petition.
The petition and supporting documents must adequately describe the types and potential location of facilities needed to operate the size and scope of the educational program proposed in the charter.
In the event a specific facility has not been secured, evidence must be provided of the type and projected costs of the facilities that may be available in the location of the proposed charter school.
It must reflect reasonable costs for the acquisition or leasing of facilities to house the charter school, taking into account facilities that may be allocated under the provisions of Prop 39.
So the Winton petition provided a specific address for the charter school facility, which is very, which is a little more rare.
We usually just, it just proposes a location.
In this case, it actually had an address.
So because there was no additional information provided in the petition documents, we reached out to the lead petitioner and requested a copy of the lease agreement, assuming that there would have been one.
Dr. Martinez was not able to provide one, but instead provided a copy of an intent to lease confirmation.
which was dated fairly old, it was about 21 months old, so it was a little bit older.
And we looked at it, but the address was different than it was in the petition.
So we followed up again about the discrepancy, and Dr. Martinez confirmed that the Winton Educational Foundation was evaluating two facilities, one at the Evergreen Christian Center, and another at the Winton First Southern Baptist Church.
either of which he believed would accommodate the 200 pupils, which is the year one targeted pupils that they're gonna serve.
We followed up with, because there was no other information provided, we followed up with the two facilities.
And we found that there had been no additional contact made about that intent to lease for the last 21 months, and there was for the center, and no contact had been made at all with the church.
So, and additionally, the officials stated that there was insufficient space to house the first year pupils.
Dr. Martinez also stated in a follow-up email to the CDE that upon charter approval, Winton will start the process of building a new facility that will ultimately house the targeted 700 to 800 pupils.
He noted a donation of a county park and or a parcel property as available land space for new school construction.
However, in our follow-up with both properties, we found that the County of Merced Parks and Recreation Department had not been contacted about the county park, and it could not be donated, and that the parcel property was not a viable option for school construction.
So as a result of the multiple facility scenarios that were provided by the petitioner, and the lack of supporting documentation, we cannot determine if the costs for the facilities included in the budget are reasonable, and what realistic facility costs have to the overall viability of the charter school.
And then the second finding, the petition, does the petition contain reasonably comprehensive descriptions of the required elements?
We find that it does not provide a description for some of the elements, including employee qualifications, independent financial audits, and the effect of the financial projections for a proposed charter school.
Other elements we found would require a technical amendment.
So based on the program deficiencies that I've summarized and presented,
These are CD's findings in support of the recommendation to deny the Winton Charter Petition.
That includes the charter petitioner is demonstrably unlikely to successfully implement the intended program, and that the petition does not contain reasonably comprehensive descriptions of the multiple required charter elements.
The Winton Charter Petitioner and I believe representatives from the district are here to address the board, and I can answer any questions.
It was a unanimous vote to deny, recommend denial.
Okay, it's been determined that just the lady here will be the one meeting someone.
Okay.
Buenos tardes.
Good afternoon.
My name is Marta Gutierrez.
I have been part of the Winton community for more than 30 years.
The number of inhabitants in this population has been increasing incrementally to more than 12,000.
The sad thing about the people and the programs of Winton have been, conditions have been worsening with time.
The interpreter is going to request a repetition of that.
The education that is given to our kids in the high school of Aguada, the majority of students do not use it to prepare.
to prepare themselves for a career in the university.
Many of our children leave school, become involved in illicit or non-lucrative activities for the increment of staff, like gangs, high criminals, drugs,
Because there are many reasons, but the most important is that they don't take advantage of the opportunities that the school does not provide for them.
The reality is that it's difficult for the majority of the students to involve themselves with sports.
after school programs, clubs, organizations and activities that will help the students.
In my family, my siblings, we are 10, but no one graduated.
I personally have three children, but
Two of them did not graduate.
Only one of them graduated.
And is not ready to go to the university.
And this organization of the Winton Foundation Education is ready.
Thank you.
So now we'll open the public hearing.
Dr. Kirst, Ms.
Chen, board members, my name is George Solis.
I'm a retired educator with 30 years of experience, 15 years as a teacher, three of which were at Winton Elementary, excuse me, and 15 years as a principal.
I'm a board member of the Winton Educational Foundation, and currently I am the acting president.
We are here to further address concerns by the board on facilities, budget, and capacity.
As far as facilities, we have contacted Evergreen Christian Center and communicated with them our intent, and we've also forwarded information as far as to costs and changes that needed to be made to accommodate the students.
We've also forwarded additional information on our budget as per the services of Spencer Stiles,
And as far as capacity, we feel that our leadership team, which we forwarded a list of to you, has the capacity and the experience to be able to lead this team.
Our Board Vice President has a brief presentation for you, and at the end, we will be happy to answer any additional questions you may have.
Good afternoon, board members.
My name is Josie Solis.
I am a credential elementary school teacher.
I hold a reading certificate and a master's degree in curriculum and instruction from California State University Stanislaus.
I have more than 25 years of teaching experience, and in addition, I am currently the vice president of the Wyndham Educational Foundation.
Our mission is to improve the quality of life of the residents of the unincorporated rural community of Winton, California, with approximately 12,000 residents.
The Winton Educational Foundation has submitted a charter high school petition as an appeal for your endorsement consideration.
I attended and graduated from Atwater High School, which is the closest high school to Winton.
Although my high school experience
was not positive, I still consider myself fortunate to have graduated.
After high school, I wanted to attend college, but I knew in my heart that I was not academically prepared.
Nevertheless, I could not give up my childhood dream of becoming a teacher.
My college years were not easy, and I had to work very, very hard, but I never gave up.
I just wish my high school had prepared me for college and paid more attention to my needs.
How can a student
just keep on going to school and no one stops to question the reasons he or she is failing.
I was one of those failing students, and it is not that I am blaming anyone in particular.
I just believe that other options in my education would have made a big difference in my life.
Since I didn't have transportation and my grades weren't the best, I was not given the opportunity to enroll in advanced courses or to participate in extracurricular activities.
I guess I was just a victim of the circumstances.
In many cases, things have not changed for the Winton High School students.
For this reason, I have made it my personal and professional goal to support students to succeed in school so they in turn become responsible contributors in our society.
No student should have to go through what I went through.
We are here to respectfully ask the State Board of Education to approve this petition in order to open a charter high school that will serve 209th grade students in August of 2017.
The number of students will increase to 400 in grades nine and 10 by the fall of 2018.
After four years, the projected student population will be approximately 800 students in grades nine through 12.
Presently, many students walk between three to five miles to the nearest high school in Atwater.
Under these circumstances, student safety is at risk due to the lack of sidewalks and high volumes of traffic.
During the winter months, this task becomes even more dangerous.
Your approval is necessary in order to proceed with the plans and to obtain the funds necessary to construct and operate the proposed charter high school, including but not limited to planning grants, facility grants, leasing grants, construction grants, loans, and pre-opening loans.
We believe this charter school petition provides reasonable, comprehensive descriptions of all required elements.
In order to demonstrate that we can successfully implement the program set forth in the petition, we have provided you with answers to specific areas of concern that the commission and charter school post on our initial presentation.
The leadership team, which is composed of experienced educators, school administrators, business owners, parents, and community volunteers, has the capacity to provide any and all support necessary to hire, direct, and oversee the startup of the Winton Charter High School.
The true test of the success of the high school will be evaluated on the basis of the academic outcome of the students completing the charter school's instructional program.
The proposed winter charter high school will strive for 100% college-ready academic outcome.
Most of the charter schools we, or the models we plan to emulate, have over 95% college preparation rates.
At the present time, according to the data, 32% of Atwater High School students are prepared for college.
The Winton Educational Foundation is excited by the prospect of offering the community of Winton access to this unique educational option.
We are honored to be part of the Winton community and partners with the State Board of Education and other organizations providing services to the students and families of the town of Winton.
With your support and guidance, this project will leave a legacy in the town of Winton that will last forever.
The community of Winton needs and deserves to have its own high school.
We feel that it is almost immoral that the Winton high school population is being negated their own high school, which is desperately needed in the community.
At the present time, according to the Merced Union High School District, there are no plans in building a high school in many years to come.
Again, we respectfully request that for the State Board of Education to approve the petition and help us fill the gaps in our youth educational process and to prepare them for a successful future after high school.
Your approval, endorsement, and support will demonstrate your commitment to respect the intent of the legislature to encourage the approval of charter schools like this one, schools that are needed and the community they serve.
Our leadership team will work very hard to make you proud of supporting our efforts.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, board members.
Excuse me, allergy.
I'm here representing the leadership team.
I work with them.
I'm employed at CSUS Sacramento for the last 29 years.
Excuse me, sir, we're gonna do public comment later.
This is the 10 minutes for the district.
I'm giving, oh, that's a part of the 10 minutes.
Sorry.
No, no, no, no, wait.
minutes when they completed.
Good afternoon, President Kirsten, SBE board members.
I'm Janet Riley, the Assistant Superintendent of Business Services for the Merced County Office of Education.
The Merced County Office of Education urges you to accept the recommendation of the CDE staff to deny the request to establish the Winton Charter High School under the oversight of SBE.
During our review of the petition, our subsequent capacity interview, we realized the petitioners are very committed to bringing a high school to the Winton community, and we commend them for their efforts to contribute to public education.
Just unfortunately, we just don't believe that they could successfully implement the program they had designed.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, I'm Scott Weimer, Executive Director of Curriculum Instruction for the Merced Union High School District, and I will speak very quickly, because that's a little bit of an intimidating light and system we have in front of here.
But I do want to commend the Board for understanding what took place for the last hour and a half, because I think I'm walking away more confused than I was when I started on the previous request.
So I give you a lot of credit for having understood the back and forth and the flow of those different systems.
At the last appeal for the Witton Charter School, there were a lot of comments, and we just heard one today, that basically implied that they should be able to have a charter school because Atwater High School is a bad school and that Witton students do not participate in activities.
So we did provide you with a handout that had information about the high school.
So just a couple of quick highlights on that.
Right as the end of the CST system, Atwater High School was a state-ranked school of seven with a similar school ranking of 10.
It has a 95% graduation rate with almost 80% socioeconomically disadvantaged students.
There are a wide range of opportunities, and we do have all kinds of AP classes, activities, and different things.
And when we broke down the numbers, they were equal between the students of Wynton and the students in other areas as far as participation in things such as football, cheerleading.
link crew and other types of things.
I do have a positive one that I get to throw out here real quickly that just happened about a week and a half ago.
Atwater High School did compete in Indianapolis in the FFA National Championships, and they did have a third place team in the milk quality and dairy foods.
Two of those four members were from Winton, and one of those members from Winton was the highest individual scorer in the country.
They also scored first as national champions in the FFA marketing plan team, and one of the three members of that was from WNTN.
So WNTN students are participating in a regular basis and in a large percentage in the activities at Atwater High School.
But Atwater High School is not the issue for today.
The charter school petition is the issue for today.
Just as Atwater being a good school is not a reason to decline, having a bad school would not be a reason to automatically accept.
So the issue comes back to the actual application itself.
And it seems to be that the petitioners are wanting to secede, basically take a community out of the district, and rather than working with the elementary school district to become a unified district and create a system like another school did about 10 years ago, they are going the charter school route.
The number 200 to 800 means every single student in Winton Middle School would go to their charter school.
So that is the basis for those figures and numbers.
It's not a district-wide charter.
It's not what they're expecting every single student there.
So all 67% who are in soccer programs, football programs, track, cross country, they're expecting to leave that.
to go to a facility that they don't necessarily have.
So that's one of the issues as far as we were concerned on the, we can't really state it better than it was stated by the staff, but the financial issues were one of the major issues.
They are vague and unrealistic.
800 students, there are no facilities that you'd be able to rent that could house 800 students in that area.
Evergreen Christian is a church.
It would not be able to handle that.
and there are no other locations, and when they start talking about the ability to be able to purchase and build their own school, there's no indication on how they would raise that money.
That would be millions and millions of dollars, and there's no indication.
The last piece then is we have concerns over the opportunities that would be provided to the students.
Every one of our schools has a school psychologist, a school nurse, a counselor for social emotional issues, and a wide variety of support systems.
And there's none of that that is identified in their system on how they would be providing that information.
We do respect and commend the parents for their concern and their passion.
We are always willing to work with parents, community members to be able to create better things and better environments for their students.
But the petition as it is here is not financially realistic, and they're unlikely to be able to carry it out.
Examples of things such as the property that they did not have a lease on and they don't have the abilities for.
Evergreen Christian is right down the street from Atwater High School.
Winton buses all of their kids around their elementary school district.
There's no indication that they would be busing those students to the Evergreen Christian Center.
So that's another piece that is missing within theirs.
So we do respect and commend the parents here for their concern for their students.
And yes, I'm very nervous.
But it is not likely that they would be able to carry out the petition that they have proposed.
Okay, thank you, and we're now ready for the public comment.
List of the commenters.
Will the following people please line up?
Sheila Witt, Angela De Ramos, Lorraine Richards, Ken Burt, Michelle Lowe, Rosendo Garcia, Gustavo Andrade, St.
Jude Richard Carrillo, Jaime Franco,
Good afternoon.
Sheila Whitley, and I'm a CTA liaison to the State Board of Ed.
CTA is opposed to this application.
I live in the neighboring community of Atwater.
My kids attended Atwater High.
I personally taught in Winton for six years.
My husband taught there for 17 years.
I currently teach in the Merced Union High School District.
And I am very, very concerned over this application.
Um, my kids attended the same school community school at water high school, and it is an excellent school and has all kinds of opportunities for kids.
During the current economic crisis that we had recently, a lot of services were cut.
Busing was cut, but a lot of that has been restored.
This is a flawed application by a questionable group of individuals.
The person in charge has had his credential revoked.
There are several doubts about the financial plans and many of the education and pedagogical proposals.
Having personal knowledge of this community, I can assure you that this charter is definitely not in the best interest of the students of the Winton community.
Thank you very much.
I urge you to deny this proposal.
Hello, Lorraine Richards representing CTA.
As mentioned previously, CTA is opposed to the application.
And as we continue with conversations here at State Board of Education, we speak about local control.
And in this case, the State Board of Education should defer to the judgment of the local district and the county as the experts of their needs represented by their government's local control.
Thank you.
Hello, I'm Gustavo Andrade.
I'm a member of the Winton Municipal Advisory Council reading a letter on behalf of Deidre Kelsey, supervisor for District 4 in Merced County.
Dear Madam and Sirs, I am writing to support the request of the Winton Educational Foundation, which is seeking your permission to form a charter high school within the unincorporated community of Winton and Merced County.
Winton is a large community with a population of approximately 10,000 persons.
Many of the hardworking people that raise their families in Winton are largely underserved by local government.
The incidences of gang violence and the lack of adequate sheriff officers has been an ongoing issue during my 21 years on the Board of Supervisors.
Infrastructure such as complete streets, sidewalks, storm drains, and street lighting are substandard.
Crime and domestic violence incidents are high in the Winton.
If I may be allowed to just finish the letter, it's only a few paragraphs left.
Can you just summarize the letter?
More or less, it discusses how the rural community of Delhi, which is roughly the same size as Winton, received a school and that in itself, among other things, helped the community recover from the position they were in at the time.
And she supports the Winton Charter High School.
Hi, my name is Rodolfo Lizama.
I'm a resident of Winton and the editor of the local Hispanic newspaper.
Education is the hope of any family and any society for a better life.
We are a low-income and agricultural community.
We acknowledge that most students have no transportation or someone to take them to school.
They cannot take advantage of after-school activities since they need to get back before it gets dark.
They are at risk of becoming victims of bullying from gang members
and by being hit by cars, and that absolutely has happened.
This lack of access empowers the students to do whatever it takes in order to get a high school education, regardless of weather conditions.
The access to a quality education now more than ever is needed and required since technology is advancing so fast and requires the students to be in intellectual shape to confront the coming challenges.
The Winton Educational Foundation is trying to reach
the gap by establishing this charter high school.
Your approval, support, and guidance can only make a positive change in our student community.
Please give these dreams an opportunity to become a reality.
Thanks.
I'm back.
I'm Roseno Garcia from CSUS Sacramento.
I've been there for 29 years.
I work with the educational department.
I have various positions there.
The latest in the last 20 years have been in the area of supervision.
I supervise K-12 student teachers, and I also supervise administrative interns.
My job has been to focus on supporting them in developing to a good, well, we used to have a bilingual program, but after 27, it faltered a little bit, but we focused on making English-only teachers become more aware of the needs of the English learners in the schools.
I work with the leadership team, and I will continue to support them and work with them.
My focus is the program development and teacher development, and of course, evaluation.
Thank you.
Hello, my name is Richard.
I'm a member of the Wynton Education Foundation.
I believe in the mission of the organization.
I grew up in the Wynton community and have seen the influence of gangs on the youth.
Because of the lack of positive activities, I want to make a difference in Wynton and I think the charter school is
one difference.
They need access to a quality education.
We need support from you to establish the charter high school.
With your guidance, professional agency, and educators, we hope to make this charter school dream flourish into reality.
We are willing and able to follow all recommendations from you.
That will help us meet the requirements for the charter school.
Please give us and yourselves the opportunity to make a difference today for the youth of Winton's future.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, my name is Javier Franco.
I work in the migrant education, and I have seen personally how difficult it is to go through everything.
Myself, I went through, I didn't work in the farms as my dad did, so all these families need that kind of assistance.
Anything that has to do with an education, we all, we need it.
Including myself, I learned the language when I was 16.
It's very difficult, and it will make it more difficult if you don't give us your guidance and your support, because this community needs it.
I've been there, have worked with parents, done that myself, and achieved higher education.
I have already achieved a university degree, so give us an opportunity to work.
My name is Floripa De Este and I would like to have a petition for do you guys think about the education in Winton that is better for the students because they deserve a better future not like parents you know like parents work a lot in the field and the students they want to study but they don't have any opportunity because some some students they walk like two miles three miles
then when they get first in the first period they get tired if that if you think if the school is closed they can do better every day also in the great and and also they can help in the house too thank you okay that concludes the public comment so we're now ready for board member comments perhaps the liaisons want us to make a comment that concludes the public hearing
So Member Holiday and I attended the ACCS meeting and listened to those deliberations, listened to the district, listened to the parents.
Without a doubt, the parents are very committed.
the groups that are here, whether other Winton students are participating in activities at Atwater, this group of parents feels like they either don't belong or their students feel like they don't belong or they
they find it very difficult to do both the walk all the way over there and back and participate with the other family expectations and obligations.
So even if it's true, which I believe it is, that Atwater is a great school and that Winton students participate in it, you still have a group of parents who feel like they need something else.
And I'm hoping that you're hearing that.
and make that a priority.
As I listen to the presentation at ACCS and listen to the deliberations at ACCS, this is my sixth year now of hearing petitions.
and reading petitions and considering capacity and which things are significant or not significant.
So I have some experience with this.
And I will say that I do feel like the capacity is not there for this school.
The heart is there.
The desire is there.
The love of your kids and wanting something better is there.
But the capacity to actually pull off a charter school, it's a tremendous thing to start a new school.
A lot of effort, a lot of talent involved, a lot of know-how.
a lot of knowledge, and my feeling is that I agree with the CDE recommendation and the ACCS recommendation that that capacity is not there for this school to be successful.
So I would make a motion to approve the CDE recommendation.
Okay.
Board Member Holliday, do you want to comment as the other liaison on this?
Not at this time, thank you.
Okay.
Other board member comments?
So I would second that recommendation.
All right.
Ortiz-Lacombe.
Voy a traducir lo que dijo mi compaera, la seora Williams.
Y dijo que es muy claro que en esta peticin hay corazn y hay mucho entusiasmo de la comunidad.
Y queremos agradecer a los miembros de la comunidad que han venido a apoyar a esta escuela.
Tambin queremos que la escuela Atwater entienda que aunque ellos sirven, estn sirviendo a una poblacin, no todo el mundo est satisfecho con los servicios que estn proviendo.
y esperemos que ellos sean ms abiertos a escuchar alguno de los comentarios, de las quejas quizs que los padres aqu han vocalizado.
Entonces, aunque esta peticin tiene mucho corazn,
Okay, thank you for that.
Comments by the board?
If not, we have a motion on the floor.
All those in favor of the motion?
OK.
One abstention?
So that motion carries.
And that concludes our business today, except for public comment.
Are there any members of the audience who want to comment on things that were not on our agenda?
Okay, then I declare the board adjourned.